los asistentes están en modo de solo escucha. ¿Qué tal? Muy buenas tardes a todos, a ver un
momentito porque lo que está pasando es que no soy presentador, no soy presentador y por eso
pues no podía compartir la pantalla, pero ya me he nombrado presentador a mí mismo y ahí estamos.
Muy buenas tardes a todos, aquí estamos en una clase más del curso de trading algoritmico,
a ver que tengo todavía que abrir algún programa. 0.5, no 0.5 no, 0.5 es 50% pero sí me da más de un
50% mirado. Hoy vamos a continuar desarrollando el sistema de ruptura en acciones, la parte
0.5. Pero de momento vamos a sentarnos en la parte tendencial y
mandaremos un cierto trabajo optativo por supuesto para para casa, pero antes que nada, antes que
nada había alguna pregunta en el discor, antes que nada, bueno lo había comentado ya Alberto ahí,
que teníamos alguna pregunta sin responder, fijaros que hay un canal donde podemos ver si
trabajamos, para que lo tomemos en consideración, no quiere decir que a lo mejor no estemos en
otro sitio, puede ser que lo hagamos, pero ahí sí que seguro que contestamos, es decir, el sitio
digamos más claro para hacer preguntas relacionadas con el curso, van ahí. Si alguien quiere preguntar
en otros sitios puede hacerlo, pero ya pues depende, te puede ser que te responda alguien,
que no, etcétera. Había habido creo un par de preguntas sobre la plataforma que ya había
contestado a Alberto, nosotros usarla como tal a nivel de trading la hemos usado, yo sí que la he
visto hace muchísimos años, muchísimos años, por lo cual la versión que hay ahora pues no sé
cómo será, antiguamente era para hacer opciones sobre futuros, no sé si será actualmente igual,
al 100%, porque te digo, estoy hablando de una información de hace muchísimo tiempo,
de todas maneras nadie mejor que la propia TrainStation te va a informar de ello, quiero
decir que al final en caso de que tengas dudas, en la web hay un apartado que lo explica, o sea,
lo que sí que es, que entiendo que eso será igual, no tiene nada que ver con la plataforma
de TrainStation a nivel desktop, la versión 10 y la 9.5, en normal y con entera una cosa
completamente aparta, así era antes y yo me imagino que seguirá igual, entonces ya digo,
nada que ver, nada que ver y estaba centrada, de hecho no era ni algorímica en su momento,
no sé si ha cambiado, estoy ahora mismo mientras te hablo mirándolo en la web a ver si veo alguna
cosa distinta, me da la sensación que no, me da la sensación que es un poco parecida y no tiene más,
pero ya te digo, no podemos ayudar mucho más que esto, si no, pues ya digo, hay un chat,
tenéis cuenta, enviar un email al client center, deciros esta plataforma para que sirva y tal,
pero antiguamente era para hacer opciones sobre futuros y era solo para eso, solo para hacer
opciones sobre futuros. Y bueno, poco más, sí, Alejandro también había hecho un comentario en
la parte de pregunta aquí con dos partes, en una nos felicitaba y agradecía el contenido, Alejandro
la verdad que es una persona bastante... del perfil alumno avanzado podemos decir, ya sabéis que
hay distintos perfiles en el curso y que tratamos de aportar valor a todos, aunque lógicamente el
que ya sabe muchas cosas, pues puedes aportar mucho en pocas cosas, porque hay veces que,
como digo, el diablo está en los detalles, hay cosas que pueden ser detalles, que pueden ser muy
importantes, pero en lo que es cantidad de información, lógicamente, pues siempre lo aprovecha
más el que empieza de cero, eso es obvio, pero bueno, luego comentaba el tema de porfolio que
echaba en falta alguna parte avanzada. Bueno, ya te comenté, Alejandro, tomamos nota y bueno,
pues a medida que avancemos hacia la parte porfolio, que lógicamente todavía falta,
porque quiero antes hacer bastantes estrategias más y pues ya veremos, a ver si podemos resolver un
poquito esa inquietud que tienes. Hoy, de hecho, vamos a trabajar este sistema en 100 acciones en
el Nasdaq, pero no con la finalidad de hacer un porfolio sobre ella, sino con la finalidad
de validar la idea, de ver si el sistema funciona, etcétera, etcétera, ¿vale? Pero un poco otro
camino que ya os comenté, que son sistemas que tienen poca frecuencia operativa, pues una de las
maneras de validarlo es juntando activos, y este es lo que vamos a hacer un poco con
este sistema. ¿Podría hacerse por otro camino? Bueno, podría hacerse, pero a nosotros en este
tipo de sistemas nos gusta mucho este método, es decir, meter todo el Nasdaq 100 o en una cesta
de ETFs o en todo el SP500, en un montón de acciones que, lógicamente, pues se comportan
de su manera, pues tratar de validar la idea, la idea ahí, ¿no? Esto por un lado, ¿vale? Entonces ya
está, creo que los demás que teníais comentarios del Discord, de acuerdo, aquellos que todavía
no hayáis entrado, que tenemos un Discord de alumnos que podéis apuntaros, por ahí ya os dejarán
la dirección, y si no nos la pedís, y bueno, pues ya está. Luego, otro tema que quería hablar, que lo dije,
que lo comentaría, lo comento ahora, es colgué la entrevista de Iván, la verdad que ahora no veo
dónde la colgué, porque ahora la encuentro. ¿Dónde la colgué? Bienvenido, quizá, sí, la colgué en bienvenido,
bueno, Iván es, aquellos que no lo conozcáis, él es el gestor de Emerging Funds, es una gestora
que tiene oficina en distintos sitios, en Nueva York, en Dubái, es, la verdad que es todo con la suerte
de que sea amigo personal, además de colega de profesión, y es un tener excelente, como ha
demostrado en su, en el concurso, que es el mismo que ganó la Rey Williams, año pasado que lo ha ganado, ¿no?
Abrí el debate ahí un poquito, aquellos que hayáis visto la ponencia, los que no hayáis visto,
yo os recomiendo verla, Robotrader, cada año participamos hace bastantes años, no me acuerdo
que ya tengo la ponencia, pero bueno, ya os avisaré, creo que era en abril, creo que era en abril,
y bueno, pues ahí cuando la haga ya os lo comunicaré, y lo había dicho,
tengo que ponerle el título, así que tengo que ponerle el título, a ver si se lo paso un día de estos,
bueno, entonces la verdad que la ponencia estuvo interesante, y lo más interesante
estuvieron las preguntas, ahí os puse como debate, ¿no?, de que habían un par de cositas en que no
estamos de acuerdo, que esto por supuesto yo lo, bueno, mira, en cierto, en marzo tengo una reunión
con Iván, y seguro que lo volveremos a comentar, pero lo que quería es que vierais, como ya os he
dicho insistentemente, la teoría que nosotros os explicamos cómo hacemos nosotros las cosas,
y os hemos explicado algunas que también no hacemos, ¿de acuerdo?, porque hay que explicar,
hay que explicarlo todo y explicar lo que nosotros pensamos, pero hay distintos caminos para llegar
a Roma, y además en lo esencial, en lo esencial os aseguro que estamos 100% de acuerdo, porque es
lo esencial, es lo esencial, ¿de acuerdo?, y de ahí no hay variación, el hecho, como por ejemplo,
cuando os expliqué, si os acordáis, el BRAC, y os dije que el BRAC, en mi opinión, a mí,
no tiene mucho sentido, pero no tiene mucho sentido, lo que quiero decir es el nombre,
¿de acuerdo?, es decir, al final un BRAC, el BRAC es, es decir, una optimización convencional es
muy parecida al BRAC, ¿vale?, y si tú haces una optimización convencional y le sacas 4.000 trades,
y no tiene muchos grados de libertad, de verdad, seguramente no hace falta World Forward,
¿vale?, pero hazlo, ¿de acuerdo?, no está de más, no está de más, al final la mayoría de traders
utilizamos varios métodos de evaluación, y realmente si están bien hechos, hay varios que son útiles,
y es verdad que para algún tipo de sistema puede venir mejor, puede venir otro, pero la idea está
clara, y acordaros cuando os dije, significación estadística, representatividad de la muestra,
esto es los cimientos de la metodología clásica, y también es lo que hace Iván, ¿de acuerdo?,
es lo que hace Iván, es lo mismo, ¿vale?, él, por ejemplo, no le gusta World Forward, a Kevin le
gusta, a Andrea Humbert, por ejemplo, tampoco le gusta World Forward, es decir, hay distintos,
hay distintos, como os digo, opiniones, y demás, a mí el Cluster World Forward me gusta mucho,
ya trataremos de hacer en este sistema, como tal, no lo vamos a hacer, porque ahora a medida que
avance la clase lo veréis, los problemas que te vas encontrando, pero en otros sistemas sí que lo haremos,
haremos un World Forward al uso, pero en este no lo vamos a hacer como tal, y podemos acabar validando
la idea, igual, ¿de acuerdo?, es decir, ahí está un poquito el tema, ¿vale?,
y bien, pues vamos un poquito a ir avanzando en la clase de hoy,
tengo tantas cositas por aquí abiertas, esto lo vamos a cerrar, dejamos este gráfico, vamos a abrir,
bueno, tengo ya aquí todo preparado, así que mira, voy a ir abriendo, voy a dejar ya el 3.6 abierto,
porque luego, si tengo tiempo, haremos una cosita en directo, haremos una cosita en directo en
porfolio maestro, principalmente aquí hemos usado un poco porfolio maestro y un mucho porfolio trader
para este sistema, pero bueno, como ya os dije varias veces y voy a insistir en ello,
pues todos tienen sus cosas, todos tienen sus cosas y bueno, por eso a veces usas una cosita
de aquí y a veces otra cosita de allá, a ver, aquí casi que voy a abrir el workspace directo,
porque si no me va a saturar mucho el equipo, sí, sí, sí, voy a abrir el workspace directo,
aquí está, es que esto, cuando estás en directo aquí también el tema de recursos,
hay que vigilarlo porque se colapsa todo rápido, vamos con ello, esto lo abro luego y aquí está,
cualquier duda como siempre recordar que ahí está Alberto, Pilar y también seguramente Víctor y
bueno, estamos ahí todo el mundo atento a vuestras preguntas, bueno, ya estáis viendo un poquito el
sistema en cuestión, me los voy a enseñar en porfolio trader por un lado, aquí está,
aquí lo estoy viendo yo y os voy a explicar un poquito el planteamiento de hoy,
PowerLenguages, antes que nada, si, nos habíais comentado lo del, la verdad que tenía pensado
daroslo hoy, me comprometo a lo largo de la semana, antes la siguiente clase, daroslo,
daroslo, pero todavía no, realmente las clases llevan bastante trabajo de preparación y no me,
era lo siguiente que me faltaba y no llegaba tiempo de hacerlo, vale, pero para la siguiente,
antes de la siguiente clase os hacemos el código, el código y demás, la idea básica porque aquí
este código realmente es muy largo pero de momento estamos usando tres cositas, ¿de acuerdo?,
estamos usando tres cositas, solo la parte tendencial es simplemente el canal y simplemente
el terelink, es lo que hoy vamos a trabajar, vale, bien, recordar el sistema que es simplemente un
canal de Donchan, el pseudocódigo de hecho en palabras, ya os lo pasaré escrito bien como Dios
pero en palabras no es más que tenemos una banda arriba de los n cierres anteriores, por efecto,
acordaros que Donchan hablaba de 20 porque era más o menos un mes, más o menos cuatro semanas,
más o menos la regla de cuatro semanas y entonces en este caso como eran acciones pues nosotros
decidimos hacerlo con los cierres, se podría perfectamente haber hecho con el máximo, hoy
no lo he probado, no lo he cambiado, el otro día ya lo jugamos un poco con ello pero lo vamos
a dejar en el cierre pero podría ser que fuera mejor el máximo, ya digo que no he trabajado a
fondo ese concepto, lo he dejado en el cierre porque a nosotros en acciones el cierre en gráfico
diario normalmente el cierre le damos bastante importancia y por lo tanto pues ya nos parece bien
trabajar con el canal de cierres, el canal de cierres también está la parte baja porque el
sistema permite hacer cortos aunque no lo he trabajado, eso de hecho es lo que os voy a dejar
para el que quiera trabajarlo para casa y ver a ver qué puede hacer y como os decía planteamos
en el código distintas salidas pero hoy vamos a trabajar solo el training, solo vamos a trabajar
también tenemos en el código planteado salir por la media central que aquí no está pintada pero
pero aquí sí, podemos salir también por la media central está planteado está también
planteado salir en n barras está también planteado salir en un stop porcentual también
en un tp porcentual por arriba es decir objetivo y stop y está planteado un training pero como ya
comentamos y vamos a evaluar un tendencial puro y para eso necesitamos dejar con los beneficios
si ponemos tp no vamos a cumplir ese requisito y por lo tanto decidimos solo entrar hoy es lo que
vamos a mirar entrar por cierre por encima del canal y salir solo por training esta es la única
salida además hablamos muy de pasada porque ya comenté que os lo enseñaría un filtro que hoy
vamos a probar también de que es esta parte de aquí a ver un segundo que voy a poner el foco vale
esta parte de aquí no esta parte de aquí no es esta parte de aquí de acuerdo este filtro atr que
simplemente es si el true range de la vela actual es menor que el true range medio mensual por un
multiplicador que vamos a estudiar pero que acabaremos dejando en uno vale porque era la
idea pero como ya os comenté a veces podemos hacer optimizaciones instrumentales para ver para
coger información de la variable y este es un claro ejemplo de bien empecemos por el principio
el principio cual es el principio el principio es evaluar el canal evaluar el canal ya lo hicimos
por un lado con con igualando el stop de los acordes y tp creo que pusimos 05 pusimos uno
a nivel de evaluación preliminar y hicimos un pequeño estudio rápido para ver si
conseguimos seguir adelante por la señal de entrada así que vimos que parecía tener cierta
ventaja y hoy hemos continuado avanzando en esa idea pero ya con la versión trailing esta es la
primera estudio que hemos hecho vamos a presentar 44 estudios vale tenemos aquí la fichita en excel
enseñaré trabajo en sí el portfolio trader pero antes empezamos por la ficha vale vamos a
optimizar o estudiar o a testear el sistema de ruptura de acciones en todo el nasdaq cien de
acuerdo en las cien acciones que hoy cotizan en las acciones cuidado aquí que esto no quiere decir
que estemos haciendo una buena simulación ha pasado de cartera porque no hemos salido en
cuenta las deslistadas y la puntuación que hay pero nosotros estamos validando el sistema
no estamos montando una operativa en la sección vemos estamos evaluando el sistema podíamos
hacerlo en apple podíamos hacerlo en microsoft podíamos hacerlo en google pero eso tendría
y nos dejaría sin prácticamente margen de maniobra para poder analizar los parámetros
porque habría una significación estadística que para nosotros no sería suficiente y una manera
de hacer esto es evaluar todas las acciones a la vez de tal manera que el sistema tenga que tener
un comportamiento bueno en la mayoría de ellas porque seguro que no ganan todas al final pues
puede de esta manera consigues mayor número de operaciones y estaremos de acuerdo que son que
es un activo homogéneo entre sí comparable y que tiene si bastante correlación entre sí aunque
ya veréis que curiosamente al final cuando os muestre un perfomance report completo de una
de una buena de la combinación por ejemplo que de que acabaríamos eligiendo para operar
y veréis que realmente muchas acciones de las acciones entre sí no tienen tanta correlación
con el operando el sistema de resultados mensuales no tienen tanta pero eso lo veremos al final bien
aquí tenemos un poco todos los inputs que hay puestos en el en el sistema nosotros aquí sólo
vamos a trabajar estos que os voy a marcar en rojo vamos a trabajar el periodo del canal que
esa es la que vamos a hacer en esta primera luego trabajaremos traen y y probaremos el filtro
de acuerdo pero es el filtro a ver si tiene algún sentido o no nada más de momento nada nada más
se podría ir hecho se debería también evaluar la parte corta nosotros hoy no lo hemos hecho pero
recomiendo que lo hagáis el que tenga la capacidad de hacerlo que no pues que lo trabaja un poquito
conceptualmente y para la semana que viene empezaremos algo más pero le haremos un pequeño
vistazo también a esta parte al lado corto de este sistema a ver si tiene cierto sentido operarlo
o no de acuerdo o qué cambios podríamos hacer para operarlo en el lado corto porque la idea en
sí se bueno canal de doldrán yo puedo ponerlo arriba puedo ponerlo abajo de hecho ya está abajo
también pero es operable igual abajo que arriba por igual yo os digo que no igual no lo es porque
lógicamente el mercado de acciones tiene un sesgo alcista muy considerable y si se puede operar el
lado corto pero hay que hacerlo de una determinada forma y tendencialmente no es una de ellas
tendencialmente no es una de ellas una de las cosas que aquí no lo hemos hecho posteriormente
cuando hagamos práctica de búsqueda de señales de evaluación de activos también lo miraremos ya
la teoría recordar que hablamos no lógicamente si tú te planteas un setup de entrada decís bueno
si yo tengo un sistema tendencial pues lo voy a operar en aquellos activos que potencialmente
tengan más tendencia las acciones de ser activo esencial no lo no es así en realidad pero no lo
es sobre todo a nivel índice cuando vas a nivel de acción lo es bastante lo es bastante a nivel
índice también es tendencial en el largo plazo pero pero contra más te vas a bajando a frame el
mercado de equity menos tendenciales y más antitencial se vuelve entonces muchos sistemas
que operan acciones operan operan índices sobre todo índices brusátiles operan más bien antitencial
o versiones tipo antitenciales no no el concepto tendencial puro que es más dado de materias
primeras visas baterías primas de divisas y de acciones como digo en contado porque sí que
podemos coger tendencias bastante buenas vamos un poco al concepto que es este y este es el
concepto entonces cómo lo hemos evaluado esto bueno lo hemos evaluado a través de por folio
trader vale que es este este programa que forma parte de multichars ya digo programas y pues
es el que hemos usado pero es usar cualquiera al final lo que hemos hecho aquí es yo os explico
lo que hemos hecho y lo podéis aquellos que tengan es la posibilidad de hacerlo aplicar a
cualquier programa de acuerdo hemos hecho como aquí en el excel alguien se ha fijado hemos usado un
periodo in sample que va desde inicio del 2007 hasta final del 2018 y desde ahí es decir desde
principios de 2019 hasta el pasado viernes hemos usado auto sample vale se podría haber dejado
un tercer periodo ya os he comentado de muchos autores que lo hacen de acuerdo que dejan un
tercer periodo le llaman de validación perfecto nosotros ese periodo como los procesos suelen
durar tiempo suelen ir desde imaginaros ahora que esto estuvieramos empezando a estudiarlo y
siguiéramos pues desde ahora hasta hasta que siga el sistema de estudio que de hecho ya lleva
varias semanas no pues ya varias semanas observando y siguiendo fuera fuera de mostra
en lo que sería una especie de paper trade en esa fase ya estaría listo solemos hacerlo así pero
es correcto también es correcto también dejar un tercer periodo no es una práctica que esté que
esté para nada incorrecta hemos adoptado cinco dólares por tel que es por ejemplo lo que cobra
hoy en día tres station aunque tiene varios planes pero es un plan común para todo el mundo
si haces más volumen todavía puede ser más barato y un tic un tic de slipage vale hemos asumido un
tic de slipage hemos optimizado bueno realmente como hemos hecho exhaustiva hemos puesto net
profit pero en realidad cuando haces exhaustiva no importa porque recoges todos los datos a ver
a qué lo que es por folio trader lo que os decía de las plataformas por folio trader en cuanto a
bactés tiene algunas limitaciones por ejemplo la información que facilita es más del pobre
a nivel de utilización el world forward es infame de acuerdo es infame a nivel de configuración y
demás sobre todo en subversión por folio subversión sistema es bastante mejor ya lo veremos en otro
momento pero a versión por folio es bastante infame y en cambio tiene una gran utilidad que
es que puede ir a mercado es decir puedes acabar de montarlo puede incluso hacer forward testing
dejarlo en simulación más para sistemas central diarios quizá no que esté y puede ir a mercado
puedes configurar el por folio imaginaros que esto final fuéramos a operar las 10 acciones podría
meter por códigos reglas de prioridad vale si caso de que no las quisiera operar todas porque a veces
eso se puede hacer yo lo optimizo en 100 pero luego voy a operar las 10 x las 10 que entre en
primero las 10 que cumplan determinada condición extra de por folio yo puedo montar una regla de
por folio no es objeto ahora este tipo de cosas ya hablaremos más cuando usemos por folios como tal
no pero los comento ya que enseño el programa pues para que lo eso entonces aquí lo que hemos puesto
es un 2% a cada acción con una cuenta de 100 mil dólares hemos metido 2% de máximo a cada
a cada acción por lo tanto permitiendo apalancar en el caso de que de que sea el caso y nada más
luego ya las reglas del sistema propiamente que ya que ya conocéis en el sentido de cierre por encima
de la banda y un trailing esto en esta primera optimización claro cuando tú evaluas recordar
la teoría una entrada hay que hacer una asumción para la salida bueno yo le puse 20% de 20% de
trailing podemos haber puesto 10% da igual le puse 10% de los decía que es pobre porque
esos son los datos que facilita a nivel de por folio bueno le puedes meter un costo fitness es
verdad que aquí tenemos tenemos que hacer uno uno propio para ese que tiene implementado
multichar tiene un sharp esto que veis justo en fitness value realmente es sharp
sharp vale pero de hecho por eso teníamos sortino pero ya no lo hemos hecho porque se
lo tiene por defecto se lo tiene lo tiene por defecto entonces habíamos usado este de acuerdo
para hacer el sortino y ahí es donde nos hemos dado cuenta que no era de por folio de acuerdo era
de sistema y por lo tanto los datos que dan no son correctos sí que sí que permiten para
este ejercicio es un dato que es útil vale es útil porque creo que la lectura que da
probablemente es extrapolable y saldría bastante análoga en el caso en el caso que fuera de por
folio pero realmente cuando tú pones unas reglas cuando tú evaluas un por folio ahí como
como se explicó esto con algunas reglas de prioridad o sea realmente el el motor del
porfil realmente lo que va evaluando cada barra de acuerdo cada barra y cada pasa todos los sistemas
por todas las barras y luego aplica las reglas de ejección monetaria del por folio entonces
el ratio de sharp el ratio de sortino lo que tú quieras hacer no lo puedes calcular sistema
sistema porque no se suman y hasta acuerdo al final al final hay que calcularlo a nivel de
por folio y entonces no se ha implementado entonces hay que hacerlo que no lo habíamos
visto pensamos que era así francamente lo digo y entonces hay que volver a rehacer este ratio
de sharp pero insisto que al objeto esto no nos serviría y para concluir que sharp tiene el
porfolio es decir no sabemos ese dato hoy en día pero sí que a nivel de comparación de sets de
comparación de si el canal de 8 o de 10 o de 14 va mejor es sí que tiene sí que consideramos que
tiene relevancia de acuerdo que es el objeto os lo explico así en franqueza porque veis que
tiene este dato negativo esto qué sentido tiene pero tiene este sentido que os digo este no es
el ratio de sharp real del porfolio sino la suma de los sistemas y de manera individual haciendo
la media y por lo tanto pues está completamente desvirtuada totalmente desvirtuada porque esto
habría que hacerlo con los rendimientos del porfolio de acuerdo aprovechando la diversificación que
da cada cada una de las acciones entre entre sí a pesar de ser el mismo sistema ya lo veis que
sí que la que tiene cierta descorregación por supuesto es absolutamente mejorable pero pero que
ya tiene una cierta cierta es con esto son los datos que hemos obtenido simplemente optimizando
el canal de acuerdo de in sample aquí tenemos
vale vale si si no estaba aquí consultando porque tengo el gráfico lo voy a abrir donde
tengo esto voy a enseñarnos cada vez el gráfico vale esta no es o si es esta no es y está si
está aquí está aquí está aquí vale es esta bueno poco a poco porque digo voy a ir enseñando
cada tengo aquí un montón de cosas para abrir entonces tengo que ir paso paso paso bien esta
es la misma optimización que veis aquí en el extra recogida pero sólo el in sample de acuerdo
aquí lógicamente sólo tenemos una variable y por lo tanto no podemos hacer un gráfico en 3d pero
si en 2d no es más que a la izquierda tenemos net profit o sharp vale este sharp falso le voy
a llamar para para que me trenais pero bueno que insisto a nivel de comparación de ser creemos
que sí que tiene relevancia vale aunque su valor no tenga sentido y el net el net profit recuerdo
el net profit vale aquí en realidad ya te digo no hay no hay una función fitness como tal porque
están todas o sea hay sólo 25 posibilidades están las 25 de acuerdo cuando yo necesito una
función fitness cuando tengo que elegir entre 1000 y me tengo que quedar con 200 entonces
tengo que decir bueno esas 200 por qué criterio me las quedo bien si yo me las voy a quedar todas
da igual igual la función fitness porque yo ahora sí quisiera estos datos les puedo hacer cualquier
cálculo en excel ahora quisiera aquí calcular algo pero de cada de cada una de ellas las
optimizaciones yo podría recoger sus datos y calcular lo que quisiera es decir al final no no
no tengo que elegir por lo tanto la función fitness como tal no es necesaria esto cuando
hay pocas variables pocos inputs pues es interesante de acuerdo aquí de momento hemos dicho que podemos
tener tres inputs en total que pueden variar pero de momento estamos trabajando sólo uno para ver
sólo la entrada sin verse afectada por la por las salidas y dejándola la salida estática dejando
el filtro de volatilidad desactivado el 0 y la salida por trailing fijo en el 0 20 para que no
varíe y por lo tanto ver el canal por sí es lo que hace vale tenemos por un lado como veis el
dato sample en el dato en sample aquí ya estamos viendo que en el gráfico pues bueno se aprecia
claramente no claramente que en el retorno la verdad que es el verde hay bastante estabilidad
vale y en share podemos decir que hay estas dos tres zonas pero donde se aprecia mayor estabilidad
aquí en el sample podemos ver que es esta zona entre aquí que podemos decir que es 8 no 8 hasta
aquí 14 de acuerdo y por aquí para toda esta zona aparentemente de acuerdo aunque aquí tenemos
un share muy alto como veis el 5 bastante bastante bueno vale vamos a ver el mismo en auto sample
siempre es el que nos da o con más información aquí también hubiera sido interesante que en esa
práctica no la no la hemos hecho pero si al final fuéramos a operar haríamos esta misma
optimización invertida para los que os lo explicamos nos gusta mucho está este ejercicio
es decir hemos hecho en sample de 2007 a 2018 y a un sample de 2019 a 2024 así simplificando mucho
pues bueno esto total eran unos 17 años 17 años vale pues hacemos 13 no a ver 17 y más o menos
4 entre 4 y 5 no entre 4 y 5 vale entre 4 y 5 pues haber hecho de 2007 8 9 10 11 a 11 12 de acuerdo
dejarlo esa parte auto sample y hasta ahora en sample al revés auto sample al final y auto
sample al principio de acuerdo este también puede ser un ejercicio aquellos que podáis hacerlo y
luego comparar el auto sample que os sale de esa manera que os sale de la otra y coger esa
esa información porque cuando salen iguales eso sí que es una prueba fantástica de lo que usted
porque en un sistema tendencial como éste es verdad que hay 100 acciones todos estos datos al
final hay mucho sesgo de muestra la práctica hablamos mucho mucho de ello si yo tengo un
activo como esta aunque es verdad que este caso ya está en este caso creo que aplica bien aplica
bien porque tienen en el periodo el sample que empieza en 2007 nada más empezar pues tienen la
crisis de la crisis del 2008 2009 aquellos pues que ya estuvieras en el mercado recordaréis
que hemos empezado aquí hemos empezado aquí más o menos más o menos para ser exactos aquí en esta
línea que os pongo ahora vale entonces sí que empieza un tiro lateral al cista pero luego viene
un desplome vale final hay dos mercados bajistas podemos decir de cierta importancia todo este
este primero cae en sample y el otro cae auto sample y un poco así está elegido pero aún así
repito que es que es interesante esta esta mezcla porque ese ese mercado sí que es común puede
haber acciones que tengan otros porque no lógicamente las 100 no tienen la beta que
tienen microsoft o que tiene apple o netflix que son acciones que tienen bastante beta con el
mercado pero pero claro la mayoría la tienen la mayoría la tienen y por lo tanto ahí sí que
en esas crisis sistémicas de 2008 2009 y el tema del covid 2020 ahí sé que cayeron todas de
acuerdo o para todas se me entiende prácticamente todas huy me avisa esto voy a quitar mi cámara
porque me está avisando que que está justito de calidad para grabar así que le le quito la cámara
la cámara que tampoco pasa nada sino si no me veis porque me está me estaba avisando el mismo
programa que la conexión está perdiendo velocidad si puedo cerrar algo más un momentito que dicen
que me viene al móvil pues no sé ver puede ser que como está en la mesa lo voy a lo voy a poner
si puede ser puede ser porque mi hija me envía un mensaje veo así que igual igual ha sido eso yo
como tengo los auriculares pues no me he enterado a ver lo pongo no molestar y todo caso lo dejo
un poquito más más alejado a ver si así vamos vamos mejor también a veces no me den cuenta yo
con las manos porque es verdad que es micro estos son muy sensibles y cualquier ruidito que haces
aquí cerca se cola se me disculpe se me disculpe bueno pero sigo todo lo que os digo de acuerdo
lo voy comentando porque son cosas de la teoría y son importantes recordarlas no pero aún así
digo nosotros nos gusta mucho hacer esta doble este doble juego por delante y por detrás del
auto sample es lo que os decía este es el de el covid que cae que cae más aquí aunque fue bastante
peor el de 2008 pero ahí ahí está un poquito el tema vale vuelvo a donde estaba bien en auto
sample vamos a abrir ahora este gráfico que tengo es ese gráfico que habéis visto es el
mapa lo que pasa que es el mapa cuando sólo hay una a ver cuando sólo hay una variable donde
entonces no se puede hacer 3d sino que estos de acuerdo es net profit contra la misma contra la
misma variable más fácil todavía obtidos a dos sample a que no t2 no es t2 no es perdón
t1 t1 a ver t1 auto sample aquí está ahora sí es claro que comprobar que sea esa es perfecto
aquí tenemos la t2 por la variable ya que tenemos el gráfico de acuerdo a los que aquí va
prácticamente a medida que aumenta a medida que aumenta degradando es verdad que el auto sample
aquí plantea cierto problema que tampoco lo es tanto al lado del sample pues menos operaciones
normal por lo normal pero ya vamos viendo que la parte baja del canal aunque en este caso por
ejemplo el auto sample con valor 1 es bastante bien no es de hecho el que gana y a medida que
va aumentando el canal va perdiendo va perdiendo rendimiento teniendo insisto el trailing fijo
veamos ahora bueno aquí vemos que en esta zona aquí donde vemos el pico claro sobre todo el
sharp es aquí no en 6 acuerdo ahí en 6 vemos una cierta cierto pico que es verdad que hay
un salto importante al 7 5 6 por ahí podía estar podía estar bien también hay cierta estabilidad
aquí vamos a acabar de ver el all data uniendo los dos vale porque al final
ahí se incorpora un poco todo y donde además tenemos una muestra pues que ronda las de 2000
operaciones las 2000 operaciones fijaros que ahí pues bueno estamos en esa zona de 6 y 10 a ver que
os abro el opt y uno all data aquí lo tenemos aquí tenemos el auto y bien aquí veis un poquito
el gráfico y lo que os decía no en esta parte la verdad que es bastante estable de acuerdo del
doctor en sí es bastante estable fijaros que la zona podemos decir que luego lo veréis optimizado
todo todo junto ya lo veremos pero es bastante estable canal de noche es bastante es bastante
estable y en esta zona entre 5 es visto 10 pues está ahí bastante estabilizado aquí para irnos
para irnos para elegir uno de momento de cara a evaluar la salida pues he cogido el 6 podríamos
haber elegido otro de acuerdo es decir no tiene no tiene tampoco una brutal importancia en este
este momento de acuerdo pero el 6 me ha parecido un buen equilibrio y es el que he decidido bloquear
para evaluar la salida de acuerdo luego ya veremos un performance report de todo de todo esto puesto
en conjunto vale el 6 fijaros que al final tienen 2430 40% de aciertos típico típico
tendencial vale luego ya veremos más datos porque aquí simplemente pues nos sirve a nivel de
compararse de acuerdo no nos sirve de mucho más bien y donde como hemos evaluado el cómo hemos
evaluado el trailing como os digo bloqueando el 6 ahora os muestro el excel de esta segunda
optimización vale que es este simplemente aquí pues lo que os digo es la misma
cantidad de datos las mismas cien acciones bloqueamos el canal en 6 y dejamos oscilar
también 25 25 incrementos entre 0 0 6 y 0 30 el trailing bueno hemos puesto 25 en uno 25
para que tuvieran la misma capacidad de variación aquí tenemos los datos in sample aquí sí que se
aprecia claramente que los datos bajos deteriora muchísimo es decir el trailing realmente
deteriora mucho a la medida que lo acercas mucho claro estamos hablando de un sistema
tendencial opera muchísimo 7000 6300 se lo lleva todo en comisiones y sale demasiado rápido
realmente no tiene no tiene sentido habría que verlo evaluado desde bastante más arriba como
mínimo mínimo 0 10 y eso pues ya digo más no 0 15 hasta más de 0 30 quizá para verlo porque
al final lógicamente estamos en diario lo que quiere es que corran los los beneficios pero
nosotros también nos interesa protegernos y protegernos de las caídas de acuerdo que
es el problema al final lógicamente si evaluamos solo net profit va a querer mantenerse dentro por
eso hay que evaluar alguna cosa más aquí tenemos este ratio de charco que no nos de una buena
lectura nos sirve para este cometido que os digo y vamos a ver el opti 1 in sample es este es este
no tío no no pero optí 2 optí 2 y 2 aquí está optí 2 in sample aquí veis en este en este
perfil es bastante distinto a la anterior porque en el anterior el doncha era bastante bastante
armónico no el cierto a la rango pues por favor cierto rendimiento aquí pues claramente no es así
tiene los valores bajos pues prácticamente no tiene sentido hasta que no llega a la zona de
0 20 0 20 algo nos estabiliza en un cierto rendimiento lo cual pues como os digo tendría
habría tenido sentido dejarlo ir un poquito un poquito más un poquito más pero bueno lo hemos
dejado ahí está hasta el 0 30 que ya creo que es suficiente bueno ahí habéis 0 20 está bien
es el que habíamos puesto antes por la que habíamos visto la evaluación preliminar la
zona de 0 20 pues puede estar bien la verdad que 0 20 de momento no apunta a ir a ir mal si
miramos el auto sample y nos fijamos fijaros que ya por este charco falso 0 18 27 26 esa zona y si
nos fijamos en net profit pues clava el máximo 0 20 0 21 26 18 es decir más o menos la misma la
misma zona vamos a ver este este gráfico este es el 2 si este es este es que si lo
legramos lo vemos aquí el gráfico pues lo que veis no claramente los las partes bajas pues
este especie de charco sí que es bastante volátil pero ya veis que no es estable es el clásico
ejemplo donde se ve que no es estable que varía mucho que puede tener un valor bueno pero lo
siguiente no etcétera y habéis que en la parte final sí que estabiliza y estabiliza en valores
en valores altos claramente entre 0 20 0 25 todos son valores buenos todos son valores buenos y
donde además recogemos una cantidad importante de 3 estamos hablando todavía en este dato fuera
de muestra autosample de 900 800 trades de ese orden y si ya recogemos los dos unidos
pues nuevamente tenemos que se va muy arriba en 0 27 el que más tirando hacia arriba 27 26 25
bastante bastante alto pero aquí a ver que os la abro la dos old data vamos a ver este gráfico
el gráfico ahora me parece que no tengo el dos soldada alberto no lo he guardado aquí pero
lógicamente este interesante que es el que tienen más trade si por lo tanto es el que
está pues más más estabilizado pero aquí se aprecia actualmente esta tendencia que ya veía
bien veis en el chapel bueno pues a partir de 0 20 podríamos haber elegido uno uno más alto
pero al final hemos preferido bloquear el 0 20 aunque repito podríamos haber cogido otro
hemos haber cogido otro pero hemos preferido bloquear el 0 el 0 20 porque si os fijáis aunque
los que dan mayor datos 26 25 también el 0 20 fijaros que tiene el doble de operaciones
de acuerdo tiene siguen manteniendo mantienen bastante buen equilibrio de acuerdo se está
bien acompañado se nota que hay bajada que vuelve a subir es decir bastante estabilizado y
tiene muchos trades nosotros en este tipo de situaciones solemos tirar siempre a más operaciones
solemos tirar más a más operaciones porque nos tira mucho la significación estadística
de acuerdo entonces aquí aunque estemos hablando viendo mejores resultados con 1500 con 1300 la
zona de 0 25 por ejemplo de acuerdo porque tampoco lo grabaríamos demasiado esto a 0 26 27 0 20 0
25 podríamos también haber elegido perfectamente este está está bien tiene un mejor resultado
pero tiene como veis 903 menos 903 menos entonces siempre que estamos ante esa dicotomía siempre
cogemos más trade siempre cogemos más trade aunque suponga un poquito menos rendimiento porque
porque más trade significa mayor significación estadística y también significa mayor respuesta
ante cambios y de hecho aunque gana mucho menos fijaros el drawdown que es bastante bastante
menos aquí podríamos hacer pero ya digo no si tiene sentido si tiene sentido hacerlo porque
realmente como hay gestión monetaria hay unos por ciento y las salidas son porcentuales realmente
el capital está bastante cualizado aunque no sea en porcentaje de acuerdo pero aún así no nos
convence del todo que no sea de acuerdo pero no nos convence del todo pero bueno ya digo que no
no está mal tampoco hacerlo está mal esto es lo que mucha gente llama un recovery factor pero que
es net profit partido por por drawdown la verdad con los datos que tenemos aquí pues es de las
pocas cosas que podemos hacer de acuerdo y pues podrías podrías hacerlo y como veis 0 20 es el
que mejor que cualquier sin haberlo hecho pues ya ya veis ya veíamos que esa zona es la que la
que equilibra porque porque tiene muchas operaciones y tener muchas operaciones normalmente mejora la
respuesta ante ante hablando de un tendencial hablando de un tendencial mejora mejora la respuesta
ante caídas y demás claro hay que estimar bien los costes de acuerdo que se más bien los costes
porque dices tú estimas que prefieres operar mil trens más pero eso solo te va a servir si has
estimado bien los costes y si realmente tienes un tipo de deslizamiento podrías hacer ahí también
una prueba de sensibilidad deberías de mirar bien esto y probarla también en dos tics es decir bueno
pues mira no lo tengo claro voy a volver a hacer la optimización con dos tics en vez de un tic a ver
qué tal a ver cómo lo veo de acuerdo y si ves que no lo ves claro pues podrías entonces decantarte
más al 0 25 pero nosotros aquí nos quedaríamos con el con el 0 20 porque 2400 operaciones con
dos inputs solo además optimizados de manera separada está realmente realmente bien que es esto
luego no quiere decir que lo operamos en las 100 acciones de esto ahora perfectamente podríamos
luego pues operar las 10 acciones de mayor capitalización por ejemplo por elegir un
criterio no debería de operar las 10 también podría hacerlo pero que no es obligatorio no
quiero decir que esto lo estamos haciendo para validar la estrategia para tener una
mayor significación estadística pero no es obligatorio que luego en nuestro plan operativo
o usemos todas las acciones pues aquí hemos bloqueado 0 20 de acuerdo hemos bloqueado 0 20
espérate que vamos a meter este este dato en todas las tablas de acuerdo con es más que el net
profit partido por el máximo 0 18 0 15 y aquí en el otro sample menos de profit partido por
máximo del lado lo multiplicamos por menos 1 para que no dé un número negativo y estamos
0 12 0 15 varía varía un poquito 0 20 está a mitad de a mitad de tabla en el caso auto sample vale
bien este lo voy a guardar pero voy a hacerlo también en la excel de sample perdón en el excel que
lo hemos hecho solo de old data que no lo había hecho ahí lo voy a hacer ahora un momentito porque
es interesante también verlo y con los pocos datos que nos da en este caso luego pasaremos
a maestro y veremos más más información no más el problema que tiene es que es casi posible pero
es imposible pero es muy difícil optimizar con él porque da muy muy pocos muy pocos vamos siguiendo
por ahí la clase del toque de 86 aquí recovery profit partido por máximo bueno ahí veis 5 13 12 12
6 o con lo que más vale que es al final los habíamos quedado también pues con esos 2.406 que
es la misma final porque en la primera llevamos elegido 0 20 pero es verdad es casualidad no
habíamos quedado con 0 20 por defecto vale y vamos con la tercera la tercera hemos
ido a probar un filtro que es totalmente opcional y no es obligatorio pero hemos querido ver hemos
querido ver porque queríamos introduciros un filtro volatilidad aquí para un tendencial y
así pues ya explicároslo pero como digo no es obligatorio pero lo hemos probado vale bueno
para ver un poco como oscilaba que este sí que teníamos muy claro que no le íbamos a dejar este
nivel de granularidad pero queríamos ver un poco queríamos analizar cómo se movía se movía el
tema de acuerdo y hemos dejado el 6 fijo hemos fijado el 20 y hemos dejado el filtro aterre que
es el multiplicador recuerdo que le damos a la tierra ahora nos voy a enseñar en el gráfico
ha quedado claro también hemos dejado oscilar 25 vale esto esto cómo funciona vale esto cómo
funciona el código es simplemente el true range de la vela actual a ver si lo puedo enseñar
aquí en el gráfico aquí abajo fijaros tengo tengo dos aterres pintados y no sé cómo se ve
porque lo voy a poner un poco más grueso voy a poner un poco más grueso para que se vea mejor
ahora se verá mejor supongo hay dos hay dos aterres metidos en el mismo gráfico es lo mismo de
acuerdo porque el true range es el a ver a su vez de una barra de acuerdo entonces yo he metido el
a ver a su vez de uno en amarillo y a la ver a su vez hasta porque está de 14 perdón está mal
porque es el que se mete por efecto no lo había había cambiado es el de 22 porque 22
bueno porque es un mes más o menos sin más no hemos no lo hemos optimizado se podía haber
hecho una una un pequeño mapa pero a ver la pena con este tipo de cosas la verdad porque al final
lo que queremos es ver si la volatilidad va a variar nos hace un filtro volatilidad lo que
hace es comparar la volatilidad actual con la volatilidad de x periodo hay varias maneras de
hacerlo eso que te crea te crea desde el estándar hay algún estudio con el bix que espero en el
curso poderlos mostrar alguno acuerdo con la curva del bix método poco avanzado y creo que
no tocaba en este momento el curso y ese es un método sencillo que al final tiene bastantes
aporta aporta valor aporta aporta más valor de los sistemas de ruptura y a tendenciales que
no tendecía el puro pero bueno lo hemos querido meter para explicaros lo y ya está y se puede
usar simplemente comparar lo que os digo la volatilidad actual la volatilidad de hoy de
la vela actual que esto es esto ahora mismo está hoy recibiendo datos efectivamente está ahí subiendo
estos serios por ejemplo esto es apple y pues tiene la volatilidad de hoy es la barra
amarilla con la volatilidad media del último mes como veis es bastante más alta de decir
está haciendo todos estos últimos días como veis está teniendo una volatilidad baja de acuerdo
para su volatilidad media del mes y esto es lo que evaluamos simplemente de acuerdo ese filtro
consiste en el código que no es perdón consiste simplemente que si esa volatilidad por un
multiplicador que vamos a suponer que es uno vamos a suponer que el multiplicador es uno
con lo cual no es importante decir que es la volatilidad si esa volatilidad de hoy es
menor que la volatilidad de todo el mes si eso se cumple es decir si la volatilidad de hoy es
menor entonces puedo operar si la volatilidad es mayor no esto es el filtro podemos decir natural
para ir largo en tendencia porque normalmente sabemos que el mercado sube con poca volatilidad
y baja con más volatilidad entonces cuando la volatilidad está alta normalmente por eso está
el filtro así lógicamente habrá veces que no pero normalmente el mercado está nervioso el mercado
está tenso y así no se sube acuerdo el mercado tiende a subir tranquilo es verdad que cuando hay
una vuelta del mercado bajista pues ahí puede esto puede hacerte este filtro que a
mejor tardes un poco en volver al mercado hasta que no se tranquilice pero bueno pues perfecto
no al final al final lo que hace es tratar de eliminar operaciones cuando hay volatilidad
elevada es decir cuando la volatilidad de hoy es más alta que la medida podría incluso probarse
con más que en vez de la del mes fuera del trimestre es decir estaría bien es decir estaría
bien porque a lo mejor es que no yo yo sabes que como voy de largo plazo prefiero evaluar contra
la volatilidad de más de más periodos lo podemos lo podemos mirar hemos hecho con la con un mes
pero pero hubiera tenido perfectamente sentido hacerlo con con más con lo que os digo porque
al final pues yo que sé vais a ver que se vuelve mucho más tranquilo no le pongo pues
60 días por decir algo 60 días es que pues se vuelve más más estable de acuerdo se
vuelve más más estable seguimos teniendo una volatilidad baja pero se vuelve un poquito más
bueno más como decirlo más rígida no pero al final tiene más periodos recogidos entonces
tendría tendría las dos cosas sentidos y habría pues que evaluar un poquito muchas acciones como
como ya hemos dicho para ver a ver cómo como como hemos hecho con un con un mes y eso que
hemos hecho en la opti número 3 lo que hemos hecho en la opti número 3 que la tenía por aquí
preparada ver simplemente bloqueado el 6 bloqueado el 0 20 acuerdo y he dejado de 0 a 240 por dejar
25 pero ya os digo que no en este caso no le vamos a hacer queríamos simplemente analizarlo
ver un poco el mapa y aquí lo tenemos vale en esa primera vamos a hacer ya lo de recovery
que con los pocos datos que tenemos aquí pues no podemos hacer muchas más cosas ahora que
tenemos hasta algún dato negativo todo el cabono porque era negativo el profil no sí bueno y ese
73 a bueno bueno claro fijaros no mira es el clásico ejemplo de poca significación estadística
este con con un 0 2 multiplica pero tampoco que realmente no opera de acuerdo no opera nunca
entonces bueno no lógicamente no tiene no tiene sentido con cero con cero para que para que lo
tengáis en cuenta equivale no usarlo es que cero este valor que os marco equivale a no usar filtro
es la versión sin filtro y me queda un recovery de 254 aquí coloca muy bien hay alguno que
coloca ligeramente mejor ligeramente si no incluso bastante mejor vale pero
también el no usarlo queda bastante bastante equilibrado vamos a ver el mapa vamos a ver el
mapa en sample ahí lo vemos 0 es el que queda vez aquí el 0 1 pues queda esta bestial bajada
y a partir de ahí pues a partir de uno veis estabiliza mucho por por sharp y sí que aquí
entre la zona de 0 9 1 1 1 es donde tienes es decir en 1 de acuerdo ahí está claro que nos
queríamos con uno que es lo que os decía este realmente nunca lograríamos así lo
podemos usar en 0 en 1 en 2 si me apuras un 1 y medio vale 1 se suele hacer así el
aterre un aterre y medio 2 aterres 3 aterres de acuerdo no vamos a ir a 1,3 aterres con
lo que os decía de el sentido común y la lógica en cuanto a los incrementos de acuerdo no vamos
a poner 0,33 aterres vale porque eso es una sobre optimización de manual de acuerdo manual
a ver que me han levantado la mano alberto vale bien me comentan el recovery bueno el recovery
recovery simplemente el nombre no importa porque no en todas las plataformas se llama recovery
acuerdo es net profit partido por drawdown vale y esto como el drawdown está negativo se multiplica
por por menos 1 se cambia de signo para que no tenga un valor negativo pero es net profit partido
por drawdown vale net profit es lo que han ganado los cien el sistema aplicado a las
cien acciones y el drawdown es el que ha tenido el porfolio esto sí que es del porfolio está
bien de acuerdo está bien calculado por lo tanto al final es un buen estimador de retorno riesgo
entre esta está el tsi que es justamente este ratio multiplicado por los winners que es el
número el porcentaje de ganadoras de trades acertados vale es otro ratio que se llama
tristation index que es de este estilo vale cuando hablamos de las funciones fitness pues
hablamos muchísimo de esto de retorno de drawdown y hablamos de retorno riesgo de muchos y os dije
que todos tienen mucha correlación y que a nosotros nos gusta mucho el sortino vale trabajé
muchos rutinos os acordáis y también nos gusta bastante loop y vale los iremos viendo durante
el curso de acuerdo los iremos viendo no os preocupéis aquí me interesa ir introduciendo
las cosas poco a poco y en este sistema tendencial que acordaros hablamos que es para un perfil de
medio largo plazo que no necesita una implicación una dedicación continua que no quiere estar todo
el día pendiente del mercado pues bueno buscamos de entrada una estrategia de este estilo y
decidimos usarlo por doncha porque había salido mucho en el curso haremos muchas más cosas y
veremos distintos ratios pero al final es un ratio de retorno de acuerdo que al final casi siempre
son los que son más interesantes de acuerdo ratios de retorno riesgo porque al final retorno
es lo que nos interesa ganar pero el riesgo nos interesa mucho controlarlo porque cuando uno no
controla riesgos se va a tomar bien toda la farola entonces no queremos irnos a tomar bien todo el
mercado y sobre todo cuando uno empieza debe fijarse más que nada en el riesgo porque el
riesgo es lo que nos saca de la partida es lo que nos envía para casa y no podemos permitir
que nos envíen para casa de acuerdo eso es lo que no podemos permitir bajo ningún concepto y por
eso es vital vital vital controlar el riesgo vale vamos al auto sample estamos evaluando el filtro
estamos evaluando el filtro por si solo habiendo bloqueado el canal habiendo bloqueado el canal
en seis que francamente podría haber estado en otro y en 0 en 0 20 el tréil que también
habían varios pero sé sí que pues por ahí parecía equilibrar bastante bastante bien
que haces el directo que dicen no a ver a bueno aquí hay combinaciones como habéis visto antes
0 1 0 2 pues el auto sample en este caso dan 0 y fijaros tiene divisor por 0 porque es que
no llega ni a operar el auto sample no no hace no hace trade pero aparte de eso es que en auto
sample justo el valor 1 es el que queda mejor colocado en el retorno en retorno vamos a ver
el mapa el mapa y t2 no pero no t3 auto sample aquí lo tenemos que lo tenemos carlos en la parte
baja pues que no vale la pena ni comentarlo y a partir de ahí 0 9 1 1 1 2 5 toda esta zona
que ahí ha cuidado el caso 7 veces para que empieza a degradar en la zona de 1 la verdad que
está bastante 1 1 2 está bastante bastante cómodo bastante cómodo ahí también aquí en el recovery
pues se aprecia poco eso es el recovery al final se aprecia un poco eso el 0 coloca bien en 0
coloca coloca bien vamos a ver en el old data que es donde al final siempre hay más trades por lo
tanto más significación estadística y que al final recoge la parte optimizada y la parte no
optimizada está bien analizar el old data no penséis que la teoría que lo hicimos al final
está bien comparar el sample comparar el sample es muy importante perfil de optimización acordaros
y bastante interesante esto de el auto sample por delante el auto sample por detrás moverlo de
acuerdo mover la muestra que es parecido a lo que hace el braque pero nosotros no le hemos puesto
nombre pero pero es parecido a lo que hace el braque y pero al final la elección puede
perfectamente hacerse con el old data de acuerdo pero siempre que haya significación y que sea
concordante con lo que hemos visto en el auto sample y el sample final eso es la unión de los
dos el hecho hace que la caudman y es lo comparto una cosa es la variación de la cosa y es la
selección de parámetros le decía yo para elegir los parámetros cojo la optimización hasta ayer
solo decía caudman hasta ayer porque porque me interesa me interesan los todos los datos
disponibles yo ya he evaluado el sistema considero que es robusto considero que la franja de
optimización imaginaros aquí la zona de entre 6 y 12 por ahí o vale y el trailing pues lo voy a
dejar ya fijo en 0 20 voy a ver el canal bueno pues a lo mejor optimizo sólo el canal con 0 20
filtro el filtro en 1 y el trailing en 0 20 y le voy a optimizar solo el canal le meto todo el
histórico que tengo y le meto hasta el último día y con eso el hijo puedo perfectamente hacer eso
sería un comportamiento correcto con la idea ya validada con la idea ya validada y considerada
robusta y en la zona que yo voy a voy a operar y ahí la elección la haría mirando varios casos
miraría sortino de acuerdo del sample de distintos ratios miraría aquí recovery pero podría hacerlo
con el old data y optimizado hasta el último día perfectamente aquí veis lógicamente los primeros
saben con un recovery muy alto porque no operan pero luego pues ya nos vamos a ir unos 4 0 4 0
acuerdo aquí el 1 cae un poquito más nos sale en recovery también puntual de hecho el recovery sale
bastante mejor el 0 bastante mejor el 0 que el que el 1 de acuerdo con lo cual aquí operarlo o no
está dudoso está dudoso está dudoso vale ser uno es aquí vamos a ver el mapa y por qué sabroso
bueno es algo que es normal porque eso que os digo en los tendenciales puros es no son los filtros
no son tan eficaces donde son muy eficaces en los temas de breakout en los temas de breakout que
este lo haremos breakout no hoy lo podemos plantear pero no lo hemos analizado que hemos hablado de
él pero como breakout es probable que aporte más es probable que aporte que aporte más aquí es
discutible aquí es discutible pero lo queríamos explicar y ver cómo lo hubiéramos analizado que
es un poco al final de acuerdo no no metido a saco todo optimizado y a ver qué nos sale no
claro lo veremos eso también ahora veremos todo optimizado a ver qué nos ha salido a ver y 3
all data aquí tengo el mapa aquí está vale lógicamente los valores bajos pero ahí veis a
partir de 1 pues queda bastante estabilizado lógicamente el 0 el 0 también está ahí pues
bastante alto vale pero aquí eso 0 o 1 de acuerdo no hay no hay más es el es el juego que yo que yo
haría un poco el 0 o 1 por recovery aunque es un tanto precipitado no no es tan este no es tan
concluyente esto pero no cobrir tampoco es la planación de versa quiero decir que no ahora no
no si recovery no da no no es así hay otros factores pero se dieron poco los dos candidatos
de acuerdo aquí tenemos 2.400 y tenemos 2.200 en esto aquí lógicamente me podías decir no no
estaba viendo es que hemos tenido a ver déjame mirarlo aquí no abiertas tantas que las voy a
saber no ya no sé cuál es cuál es cuál a ver opti 3 opti 3 la data está aquí está el 1 si
si 1477 y el 0 aquí en 14 vale en 14 yo aquí francamente con esta información no lo veo muy
claro que habría que realizarlo un poco mejor pero sí que perdemos 206 en un filtro es para
perder 3 y cuidado con el nada si es lo que pasa que fijaros que ganamos un poquito de un poquito
de profit pero perdemos la blanca entonces a costa de ese ese profit no no sabes ganar
realmente no acaba de conseguir reducir el riesgo que es quizá donde más debe actuar
filtro de acuerdo saqué un filtro al final que estoy buscando yo estoy buscando pues evitar
trades negativos es verdad que mejora el porcentaje de acierto que es lo lógico pero no hay mejor el
drawdown esto habría que profundizar un poco más podemos hacer esto vamos a intentar mirarlo
esta hora te había pensado cuando hagamos la pausita de cinco minutos tratar de montarlo
ayer y lo podemos lo podemos mirar pero yo con esta información en el filtro la verdad no lo
veo bien le he hecho toda junta porque porque quería mostraros el mapa 3d de acuerdo queríamos
el mapa 3d y entonces hemos hecho esta opti junta que es la opti junta pues el canal de
1 a 25 el trailing de 6 a 30 que de 6 hemos visto que no pero por hacer la misma y el filtro 0 o
1 0 o 1 simplemente es decir no o sí pero con uno también quizá mejor en vez de 22 a mejor va
mejor poniéndole más más un periodo mayor la verdad que no lo hemos mirado pero podríamos
podemos directamente mirarlo nos llevaría mucho rato y puede ser porque a lo mejor simplemente
la volatilidad de un mes pues es una comparación demasiado cercana pudiera ser pero pero vaya así
excursito sí que da una cierta mejora pero no en ratios de no en el recovery da una cierta mejora
rendimiento pero no a mí no me no me convence porque un filtro es sobre todo sobre todo para
mejorar el perfil de riesgo pero bueno hemos hecho esa optimización aquí ya tenemos 1250 combinaciones
con las sin acciones ya es un poquito más intensiva pero realmente por los grados de libertad que hay
se podría hacer podría hacer pero bueno yo he preferido enseñaros la si para que la vierais
paso a paso vale bien tenemos aquí el sample vamos a poner aquí también el recovery vale con
profit dividido por máximo lauda operamos por recovery aquí fijaros que nos da en el
sample nos da el mejor el filtro activado 25 y 0 12 0 12 de decir bastante distinto lo que hemos
elegido en muy distinto vamos a ver el mapa de esto vamos a ver el mapa de esto 84 in sample
aquí podemos ver el mapa en 2d mirando a una variable o podemos mirar el mapa en 3d para
mirar el mapa 3d también tenemos que hacer alguna asupción porque tenemos tres variables
que bloquear una que es fácil porque como tenemos el 0 1 pues le vamos le podemos poner el 0 vale
o le podemos poner el uno 0 y le podemos poner vamos a hacer lo grande para que así veáis el
gráfico lo mejor posible lógicamente lo que os decía veis el trailing aquí no tiene mucho sentido
de verdad pues ha sido cortarla hecho podemos hasta hacerlo esto aquí no me dejas a pensar
que se podía bueno creo que sí que se puede dejar aquí lo que puedo es pintar las dos del 0
y el uno veis ahí podéis veis que la verdad que no creo que se vea muy bien este con el 0 y el
1 lo puedo poner que marcar una u otra es el 0 es quiere decir que con el valor 1 aquí en esta
parte de valores más bajos pues parece ir mejor pero va bastante en línea en cambio en el 1 pasa
lo contrario los valores bajos va mejor lo voy a poner bloqueado porque así queda un poco para
ver lo que en directo creo que va a ser más más confuso así que voy a activar esto la barca de
agua para que la quita a veces ayuda un poco a ver si así nos molesta lo de abajo no hay
vemos un poquito esto sería bloqueando el 1 lo que os decía el canal vez canal es muy estable es
el canal no acordaros lo que lo hicimos en excel es que os decía vez así se ve parecido
esto es lo que vemos en excel que ya os lo comenté multichats lo hace porque no tenemos
en excel también lo podemos hacer en excel pero multichats lo incorpora es bastante interesante
aquí en las partes bajas del canal como degrada muchísimo pero a partir de 5 o 6 veis ahí en un
poquito estamos en el in sample ahora o iremos pero es bastante estable bastante estable y la
zona del filtro sí que lo hemos quedado un poco bajo parece que es más alto pero lo que les decíamos
de los trades pero hay que verlo hay que verlo 0 20 está ahí al borde de gradar está al borde
de gradar está un poquito justito pero 20 es un poquito justito ese es con el con el filtro
activado y con el filtro desactivado fijaros y con el filtro desactivado parece que alarga un poco
más pero es que parece que parece que la llenura llega un poquito más allá no así es desactivado
es muy parecido pero ya vemos que todo pues toda esta zona 0 20 0 25 en el caso del filtro y
don chian pues ya digo desde 6 7 8 10 20 es decir es muy estable es muy estable tiene pocas pocas
diferencias de acuerdo esto al final que está indicando lo que muestra es estabilidad está
simplemente es estabilidad lo que es lo que queremos esto es lo que llamamos un mapa de
optimización que hay muchos nombres en la literatura dependiendo de nombres pues más guays como todos
pero esto es el mapa de optimización de toda la vida que hemos hecho que nos vas a ver más sensibilidad
de variables a mí que me interesa pues variables que su vez sus vecinos estén bien decir esto es
bien esto es bien para el lado del canal para el lado del teletrello parece que degrada más pero
tiene un punto falso porque como lo hemos graduado tanto la mente nos esga un poco por eso viene bien
el watermark este para evitar no ver un poco eso no nos esga pero realmente también es bastante
grande la zona también es bastante grande tenemos una zona aquí realmente grande que sí que quizás
más 25 habría que estudiarlo mejor esto yo me he quedado en el 0 20 por lo que os he dicho
los trains porque considero tener suficiente margen todavía para caerme mucho pero es verdad que 0 25
se ve más cómodo a nivel de estabilidad se ve más más cómodo y que incluso el 6 lo mismo en 6 quizá se
ve un poco más cómodo la zona de 15 de 12 12 0 25 quizá parece más estable parece más estable
en este gráfico de ese orden pero bueno que estamos en el in sample vamos ahora al auto sample a
ver qué conclusiones sacamos aquí lo que hemos dicho aquí parece en el mapa a mí lo que veo un
poquito más estable es esta zona aquí más o menos es 0 12 es este 12 por ahí 16 pero 12 0 11 claro
es que hay mucho trailing ahí todos están ahí es en la zona de recovery alto no cero 12 no
perdón cero 20 pico perdón perdón me equivocaba me equivocaba esto es demasiado bajos lo de más
abajo equivocado equivocado veis dame ya mejor recovery pero en el mapa no se ve tan estable
es esto esto es muy buen ejemplo para que veáis que a veces lo cerrado no que a veces no es el que
el que es aquí bueno ahí estaba el filtro activado es activado pero aquí alterna activado y no
activado que parece más activado vamos a ponerlo en activado y está esa y espera que me gusta más
que se vea el gris también la volumen al gris es aquí esta zona no con el 1 con el uno que se mueve
un poquito es claro es que el que es es detalles ya digo estar ahí todas el 0 es lo que os decía
parece más estable parece más estable 0 pero dentro de la zona cómoda vez es más más abrupto cambio
el uno perdón 0 poquito más estable es un poquito más estable se mueve pero es un poquito más
estable entonces en el 0 sí que iríamos por esa zona más o menos más o menos pero en cambio fijaros
que ahí nos están saliendo que los mejores da muy bajo da un recovery recovery de equilibró entre
retorno y riesgo da muy bajo que estamos mirando en el profit podíamos mirar también recovery
por el recovery no porque no lo no le metió en el modelo podría mirar de la hora por ejemplo
vale podría mirar a bravado
ese es el bravado que fijaros que cambia completamente el el profit lo da en la
parte alta el bravado lo da bajo en el 0 a 0 8 por eso viene bien el recovery no lo lo
podía haber metido como fitness pero no lo he hecho entonces ahora no lo puedo lo podía hacer
pero no lo tendría que hacer lo podía ver con un archivo para que prepararlo y no lo tengo listo
lo que sí que podemos meter aquí es el el sharp el sharp este falso que tenemos pero bueno pero ya
digo que es es es falso pero pero sirve un poco veis como al final lo que os digo en esas zonas
sigue tirando más para el profit y aquí se ha igualado más ya no es tan dramático la caída
porque porque el riesgo en la parte baja también lo conciberá bajo cuando lo consideraba pero
estaría bien bien verlo en el recovery que un poco lo vemos aquí pero pero eso que os digo
el recovery cambia un poco pero por net profit ahí el mapa en el profit está bien está bien está bien
también teniendo cuenta donde saldrá el recovery estaría estaría muy bien pero fijaros cómo
estabiliza en este este sharp la zona ya se vuelve absolutamente plana plana plana tanto con 0 como
se nota planísima realmente es enorme no aquí hay un poco de cráter pero pero si es ahí de la zona
0 25 es donde empieza la zona plana lo que pasa que está ahí también lo de los tres bueno este
es el sample sample vamos ahora a ver el auto sample es muy muy interesante poco para que veáis
cómo tenemos que analizar los los sistemas de este tipo que al final tienen pocas operaciones lo que
hacemos juntar acciones y a través de ellas que esto quiere decir que no va a ir óptimamente
en ninguna pero va a tener un buen equilibrio entre todas por tanto es más robusto mucho más
robusto adaptarse a todas que adaptarse a una aparentemente mejor adaptarse a una sí claro si
tienes la certeza que el ajuste va a ser en el futuro sí pero se explica mucho en la teoría al
final no tenemos certeza sobre el futuro tenemos que tratar de poner las probabilidades a nuestro
favor y eso pues lo hacemos sobre todo pues priorizando la robustez y como con este ejemplo
que estoy poniendo bien aquí en el auto sample bajamos número de trades y aquí fijaros que el
mayor recovery lo lo da a cero el canal en uno y 0 11 por decir súper rápido operando un montón
pero fijaros que pues bajando bastante el rendimiento pero también el dragón y cuidado
también el dragón interesante no aquí en la mayoría todos porque como ni fijaros que están
en el 1 en el 2 en el canal el canal súper súper bajo hasta que no llegas aquí 11 5 20 no empiezan
a aparecer algunos otros pero realmente lo dan los sex que son muy muy rápidos aquí insisto que
convendía hacer un más sensibilidad al slip y tener claro que uno puede ser dependiendo de
qué acción puede ser un poco justo un poco justo de hecho los futuros muchas veces metemos uno y
medio aunque es depender porque aquí vamos compramos en realidad compramos en la apertura
la apertura tiene mucha mucha volatilidad entonces no no necesariamente el slip de apertura tiene
que ser contrario porque como vamos en ruptura pero de datos de cierre a veces entra mejor decir
no no no es un sex como claro pero hay que contar que que que de media el normal es que sea negativo
pero habrá muchos que serán positivo en este tipo de entrada bien vamos a ver el mapa vamos a ver
el mapa en este en este caso es aquí lo que os digo ya las optimizaciones como que no son
tan claras porque porque hay demasiadas variables de acuerdo y por eso lo que lo que os he enseñado
de esto paso a paso no siempre es mejor de esta manera no hacerlo de manera independiente que
también se puede hacer y podemos también sacar conclusiones con una opinación global no existe
mal pero es mejor práctica hacerlo una a una de acuerdo a hacer conceptos independientes primero
el canal para la entrada luego para la salida bien el mapa del auto sample lo tengo aquí estamos
creo que estoy en el perfecto bien estamos caros que hay los vértices los vértices del
trailing no ya se vuelven más ásperos los vértices más ásperos estamos con el filtro activado
pero el filtro es activado es parecido cambia un poco pero es parecido en el
plazo que cae a medida que se va para hacer el canal aquí es un poco al revés lo que hemos
visto antes que el canal corto rápido bueno también porque está afectado por la última
parte de mercado los últimos años y pues bueno nos ha interesado ahí ser más rápido aquí si
metemos drawdown vamos a ver el gráfico por drawdown como cambia no se vuelve absolutamente
extraño donde quiere el canal aquí todo lo contrario es el canal muy elevado muy elevado
y con un trailing muy rápido de acuerdo muy rápido eso es lo que quiere pero no tener
lógicamente a nosotros nos interesa el equilibrio porque es solo por si solo pues no aporta no
vamos a ver este sharp falso que tenemos mucha estabilidad muy extraño también mucha mucha
estabilidad aquí pero más riesgo como veis en el canal corto curioso es que línea recta
tira aquí con el trailing fijo no porque te saca muy rápido seguramente sale vuelve a entrar sale
vuelve a entrar sale vuelve a entrar y hace muchísimas operaciones pero bueno de esa
manera pues ha conseguido evitarse la seguramente las correcciones vamos a ver el old data ya tienen
poco la información de ambos bueno pues recoger y pues tenemos ahí una bajita sola en el 1 se
va rápidamente ya la zona de 20 el canal alternando entre 0 y 1 no tiene muchos es guay y el trailing
más bien bajito claro ser más bien bajito que un poquito más de rapidez poquito más de rapidez y
con muchísimos trades muchísimos muchísimos trades vamos a ver el mapa aquí estamos ahora con
uno de filtro que pues vemos inicial subida por net profit como pues lógicamente bueno lógicamente
degrada mucho al principio en ese ese trailing tan rápido y aquí lo quiere más bien alto 0 20
todavía está justo ahí parece que 0 25 es mejor profit de acuerdo se ve como se estabiliza y él
aquí sí que aparece el canal ya más bajito es el canal aparece ahí más bajito está más bien en
4 4 5 y 6 un pico pero baja rápido y cuidado bajar rápido y bajar rápido y mirar qué peligro
tiene la derecha el cercano ahí aquí parece mejor esta zona está muy sensible no muy sensible
muy muy sensible no y además con ese trailing ahí al 0 30 acordaros ya operando poco operando
poco si lo vemos en trago down ser al revés esto ya os lo digo es totalmente inverso es
totalmente inverso llanura planísima y con con el con el trailing muy muy muy bajo haciendo un
montón de operaciones pero con muy poco retorno como habéis visto antes tanto en 0 como en 1
acuerdo tanto en 0 como entonces pues no equilibra aquí el único dato que tenemos un poco para ver
mixto es el sharp falso este que tenemos es el único que podemos usar un poco de retorno
riesgo de lo que nos permite a nivel de porfolio es un sistema individual tienen más margen y
fijaros que aquí pues sí ya vemos que el don chan da igual casi que casi da igual que don chan cojamos
y que el trailing lo queremos elevado es verdad que aquí sí que el 0 20 parece tener margen tener
tranquilidad está por aquí pero más establecer o 25 de acuerdo así que viendo estos datos sí
que quizá parece mejor el 0 25 que 0 20 queremos elegir ahora lo iremos lo iremos viendo
vale bien esto cuanto a las optis que ya tenía preparados voy a hacer ahora 5 minutitos 5
minutitos de descanso y vamos luego a montar en maestro alguna de estas combinaciones generalizarlos
ahí un poquito un poquito con más con más información vale vamos a coger algunos candidatos
los vamos a y los vamos a mirar ahí en maestro de acuerdo así que de momento voy a poner un
momentito la pausa voy a poner el reloj 5 minutitos así esto así y pues ahí lo pone 8 8 y 1 así
aparecemos otra vez por aquí ahora ya sé por aquí y ya activado y activó la grabación para que no para
que no se nos olvide haber aprovechado para leer un poquito algunos temas a ver respondiendo por
abajo ahora juan me pregunta que no le queda claro cómo elegir los gráficos 3d para lo iremos viendo
cuando iremos viendo el final un gráfico 3d es una representación de parámetros lo hemos visto en la
teoría excel aquí ya lo habéis visto con multichars ya os lo dije que teníamos viendo todo de distintas
fuentes porque lo que importa son los conceptos no no pensé no queráis aprenderlo todo en un
sistema porque vamos a ver muchos al final es la la idea es una zona estable es la estabilidad
si más no tiene no tiene más que otro otro criterio aquí en mi opinión el procedimiento más correcto
era es decir la opti 1 luego la opti 2 y la opti 3 que finalmente decidimos no aplicar el filtro
os he querido hacer esta última 4 para que la veréis toda junta recuerdo pero es mejor práctica
hacerlo de la de la de la otra manera es mejor práctica hacerla que más pero bueno espera que
lo pongo abro otra vez el mapa por ejemplo por ejemplo hemos visto antes el opti 1 data aquí
vale hemos visto esta en 2d el opti 1 all data vale bueno o tampoco estaría mal hacerla hacerla
después posteriormente como esta que hemos hecho pero por mantener el ritmo a mejor hacer hacer no
estaría mal hacer la la 4 pero ya un poquito más cerrada de acuerdo es decir no no dejando si
hemos visto que los valores tan bajos de traily pues no nos convencen pues ya los podíamos
oscupir ya de cara a hacer una elección pues elegir pero pero haríamos más cosas como las
que vamos a hacer ahora en maestro pero definitiva definitiva no es más que un equilibrio recuerdo
un equilibrio entre el rendimiento el riesgo por por distintos por distintas métricas pues
el reto no puede ser en drama puede ser echar puede ser el sortino vale que como digo lo iremos
viendo a lo largo del curso y eso lo puedes hacer tú aquí lo puedes hacer a través de
el recovery excel de acuerdo como lo vimos en el curso varias veces de acuerdo haciendo
una tabla dinámica si os acordáis vale yo estoy aquí puedo hacer una tabla dinámica y de hecho
además tengo normalmente me lo hace automático que ya la excel es bastante listo a ver aquí
tabla dinámica recomendada con gráfico ahora está había una que me decía gráfico y tabla
a uno ya me la selecciona hecho recovery y aquí le puedo elegir
la verdad voy a poner recovery las dos variables y recovery vale no este lo pongo aquí recordar
que lo hicimos en la teoría lo hicimos en la teoría pasa que aquí pues bueno es lo que
digo al final tengo este cual es la 41 final sólo tengo estas dos variables una contra la otra
si metiera también el filtro entonces ya la cosa pues sería distinto pero hay varias maneras
de hacerlo pero en definitiva me he quedado así un momentito por defecto aquí de superficie y
hasta esto pero voy a vamos a poner un diseño que nos guste más y hemos hecho el mapa en un
momentito en excel aquí es igual lo voy a quitar esto y bueno pues aquí en el excel pues también
ahora yo puedo jugar un poco con ella y la puedo ir pues moviendo puedo ir aquí a la opción 3d
puedo pues hacer alguna cosita con ello esto repito que lo vimos lo vimos en la teoría bueno
poder un poquito lógicamente tengo poquito menos de margen de maniobra que multicharts que ya está
más pensado para eso pero pero es un poco la misma la misma idea es un poco la misma idea que
lo estamos viendo por recovery final esto esto es un poco la idea que la zona si os fijáis por
recovery es pues muy muy estable pero habría que ahora vamos a ver un poquito en multicharts
viendo esto que tenemos aquí alguna alguna combinación antes dejarme que lo deje así puesto
a ver luego comentaba también aquí antonio antonio que que las dudas decía que si las
contesta alberto no las contesto yo si no es exactamente así antonio es exactamente así alberto
contesta las preguntas que tienen que ver que son de rápido responder y que tienen que ver pues
con el seguimiento de la clase bueno para que nos esperemos al final pero ya os explique si
has estado viendo las prácticas directo o posiblemente grabadas que la idea siempre es
dejar una parte al final de la clase también al inicio trato de contestar las que tenéis en el
discord y vamos respondiendo un poco todas las preguntas y al final alberto digamos que las
preguntas que aportan valor a los alumnos que es lo que tú sugieres las las dejamos un poco para
el final cuando cuando las hay también además las podéis poner en discord y también si enviáis
y las trataremos de atender lo que comentas abre el micro era algo que valorábamos pero
que sinceramente creo que al final va a ser creo que puede ser contraproducente pero no por no
por eso porque sois muchos entiendes porque sois muchos pero de todas maneras no descarto al final
puedes ir escribiendo en el chat y nosotros sí consideramos que tu duda aporta como muchas yo
ya las digo que insisto que eso en principio creo que la estructura mejor era y así es como
vamos a intentar mantenerlo que mejor algún día pues se me olvide algo distinto pero la idea lo
expliqué el primer día pasa la clase verás como lo explique así que la última media hora la dejaría
para eso es decir vosotros podéis ir preguntando y aquellas que sean de contenido que creo que
pueden aportar valor para todos al final las respondemos las que alberto tiene que
responder porque si tú me preguntas oye es que no he entendido que ha dicho no sé qué o qué
el gráfico que colores no sé cuánto o algo que afecta o es que no se ve bien o no se oye lo sé
cualquier cosa que afecte al funcionamiento de la clase en ese momento pues pues él ya trata de
resolverlo incluso me lo dice a mí o solo responde él pero las preguntas que pueden ser de cierto
contenido mi idea es plantearlas así pero si creo como este caso ahora afectan a la continuidad
de la clase pues prefiero resolverlas in situ pero si hay muchas pues prefiero dejarlo para el final
porque si no no avanzamos sin más más de acuerdo no es no es base de todas maneras si en algún
momento consideramos que es bueno abrir pues a lo mejor hacemos una clase y se mira está vamos
a dedicarla a eso vale si se acumula todo con el plan y ya ya habíamos contemplado si vamos
viendo que se acumulan muchas preguntas que hay algún grupo que nos va siguiendo pues bueno en
un momento dado decir oye clases solo de preguntas de clases solo de preguntas y lo haremos y si yo
un día tengo si 23 preguntas en el disco pues lo haré en este momento hay pocas preguntas en el
disco para Antonio hay para Antonio Antonio si cuando me llenes el disco de preguntas
tengo la clase dedicada pero pero es eso al final hay que hay que hay que ir avanzando y tratar de
que todos podáis preguntar ya te digo que no descartamos si realmente creéis que es necesario
abrir el micro lo hemos pero yo creo que es más productivo y práctico ir avanzando
pero insisto que si es necesario lo haremos si es necesario lo haremos así vale
bueno antes me comentaba lo de los mapas que lo ha comentado un poco para Antonio pero el
quedaros con la idea Antonio si Antonio me preguntaba qué datos elegir de los mapas que
lo había preguntado también Juan Antonio un poco al final que no le quedaba claro cómo elegir en
los gráficos 3d es lo que os decía ahora no no no nos quedemos ahora con elegir exacto aparte
que ahora voy a ir a multicharles vamos a coger más más información más información en el mapa en
el mapa hay veces que nos servirá muy bien para elegir y hay veces que nos servirá poco para
elegir pues la zona pero por dónde van los tiros y luego yo como ya os he dicho puedo acabar elegir
en el excel excel o multicharles en otra herramienta me puede servir un poco para ver la zona elegir
el valor exacto a veces no me resultará evidente hay veces que sí veces que sí el mapa es una
excelente herramienta de sensibilidad de parámetros decir para ver por dónde van los tiros por dónde
van los tiros pero no es sota sota caballo y rey sota caballo rey la elección final por daros
cuando vimos cuando vimos las clases en la teoría que teníamos una excel que hacíamos trabajando
en sample el sample el old data por un equilibrio de datos y demás esto al final nosotros nosotros
esto final ahora y ahí voy ahora y lo acabaríamos de afinar en maestro porque porque a mí la
información que me da multicharles es fantástico porque va muy rápido optimizando es fantástico
porque tiene los mapas pero los datos que me da del portfolio son son pocos entonces como eso
maestro me da más pues por eso acabó más es lo que os decía antes y ahí voy ahí voy ahora pero
como no me dejáis avanzar pues que no pasa nada que no pasa nada que es broma me podéis preguntar lo
lo que queráis que para eso estamos ya os dije que no que no acabaremos hasta que no acabemos
el temario que yo quiero hacer así que no hay problema vale venga vamos ahora a abrir maestro
y lo que no sabe de la de antes y toco una pregunta para luego de no hay ninguna para luego apuntada
ya no veo nada rojo o sea en principio está todo el día de preguntas no hay preguntas para luego
bueno repásate ahí las preguntas si ves alguna de esto me la marcas en rojo para que luego ya la
procese así vale no hay nada para entonces más o menos vamos a lo digo para si me guardo tiempo
para luego no estamos al día de preguntas es si si preguntáis más ahora luego luego al final los
últimos 20 minutos dependerás que haya pues os dejo más rato o menos entonces tenemos aquí el
sistema de ruptura que para levantar la mano para ahora ahora y escribirán aquí tengo el
vamos a ver o configurado todo igual ya vamos a hacer de momento un 602 con 100 mil vamos a
hacer hasta el viernes pero se lo habéis pasado 20 años vamos a hacer un par o tres de portfolios
rápidamente con esta información que teníamos a ver dónde tengo el excel pero esto no por
un lado tengo este y por otro lado tengo el excel que ahora no sé lo he cerrado el excel
este es por aquí por recovery era en el filtro vamos a hacer una cosa vamos a desactivarlo
de momento vamos a ir sin filtro que es verdad que por recovery y lo vamos a hacer primero uno con
el primero que teníamos que era 6 0 20 0 0 0 0 0 20 está todo bloqueado vale vamos a ir con
2% a cada acción y eso no sí nos va a tardar un poco nos va a tardar un poquito ese problema
que tiene maestro es que esto la verdad que es un problema realmente potente pero que
teóricamente se ha quedado muy atrás y a nivel de procesamiento de información es súper lento es
súper lento otro día también trataremos de enseñarnos algo con con cual analyzer que es
un poquito más rápido 100 vamos a ver que lo tengo configurado todo igual ya vamos a hacer de
momento un 6 0 2 con 100 mil vamos a hacer hasta el viernes pero se lo habéis pasado 20 años
vamos a hacer un par o tres de portfolios rápidamente con esta información que teníamos
aquí a ver dónde tengo el excel pero esto no por un lado tengo este y por otro lado tengo el excel
que no sé lo he cerrado el excel este es por aquí por recovery
en el filtro vamos a hacer una cosa vamos a desactivarlo de momento vamos a ir sin filtro
que es verdad que por recovery y lo vamos a hacer primero uno con el primero que teníamos que era 6
0 20 0 0 0 0 0 20 está todo bloqueado vale vamos a ir con 2% a cada acción que son así nos va a
tardar un poco nos va a tardar un poquito ese problema que tiene maestro es que esto la verdad
que es un problema realmente potente pero que teóricamente se ha quedado muy atrás y a nivel
de procesamiento de información es súper lento es súper lento otro día también trataremos de
enseñarnos algo con con cual analyzer que es un poquito más rápido bien lo bueno que tenemos
aquí es podemos mirar mucho más por ejemplo la exposición que hemos ido teniendo 150 en algún
momento pero algo tengo en el mone management mal voy a usar el de voy a usar el de el de maestro
voy a usar el de maestro voy a usar el de maestro por fix x fractional a market value que para
acciones no muy bien el dito que no se explicó el 0 0 20 que lo dejo ahora no lo toco vamos a
probar la cartera 6 0 20 0 que es la que habíamos elegido inicialmente para ir avanzando en las
validaciones pero que la verdad que no tengo claro que se la mejor ahora lo veremos combinado con los
mapas ahora está mucho más después ahora ha ido creciendo un poco bueno hemos ido a 1 y medio hasta
dos veces de exposición 2 mil 943 3 147 aquí una de las cosas interesantes que podemos ver es esto
es esto que realmente hay muchas acciones que al final es 6 20 de acuerdo nos quedamos con
este vamos a comparar 2 3 2 3 por folios distintos con este setup un momento vamos a hacerlos
primero y luego los comparamos pero no vamos a ver vamos a ver qué tal no convergen pues que
es que locura si te ve el 3 a ver está en 18 0 13 a ver el mapa aquí que teníamos antes
vamos a volver a verlo ahora me dice que no me abre el archivo no te creo a ver si vemos lo
mismo aquí que allí 8 0 13 si lo que pasa que la que el recovery siempre se ve muy afectado por
el final te tira muy abajo te tira muy abajo es esta ya ya ya aquí si miras por este este
char que tenemos por eso quería mirar a varias aquí no ahora hemos mirado 6 20 que ya la tenemos
guardada vale que si la miramos tanto aquí tanto aquí como como en el excel no dan mal
sería por aquí vamos a usar el foco el lápiz 6 20 sería más o menos por aquí ya no sé
estoy buscando la manera que lo vea mejor aquí más o menos aquí 6 20 es más o menos vale más o menos
esta tenemos pero si miramos el excel puramente por datos por recovery realmente le gusta mucho
más aquí pero ahí vemos que tanto por estar como por retorno de grado muy rápido quien gana y el
drama pasa que el drama en la teoría lo hablamos bastante todos los ratios que tienen el drawdown
el denominador al final el que dirige el ratio es el drama porque como hace de divisor vale
tira muchísimo de la tira muchísimo del ratio para él vale y acaba viéndose muy afectado el
tsi lo trata de corregir añadiendo los winners al numerador vale que eso hace que los sistemas
que aciertan más que aciertan más pues suban un poco en el ratio es verdad que aquí vamos
para el próximo día me gustaría ver en este en esta cartera que nos da sortino para para todo
el rato porque ahí ahí es donde realmente tenemos un buen equilibrio vale un buen equilibrio vamos
a ver si sí para para el próximo día casi con total seguridad que lo que lo tendremos porque
hemos visto el problema que tiene el que tienen ellos preinstalado y lo vamos a corregir y trataremos
de traerlo pero con esa información realmente en este mapa para eso decía que no siempre vas
a poder elegir es complicado elegir porque realmente es casi da igual no bueno casi da
igual me refiero en toda esta zona en toda esta planicia vale si luego y ahí ya te fijas el
retorno es donde ya te vas para arriba no se te empieza pero lo tengo activado pero pocas
diferencias se te empieza a ir más para arriba es donde decíamos que interesaba más el ratio
un poco más abajo no perdón el el trailing el porcentaje de trailing más más a 0 25 porque
en el 0 20 incluso estaba estaba justo pero bueno el 0 20 al final acaba ha sido un poco un equilibrio
entre lo que quieren los ratios de de drawdown lo que quieren los ratios de de retorno riesgo
porque al tener el drawdown el denominador tira mucho de él y el profit el profit quiere un muy
elevado si ordenamos sólo por profit vale fijaros un poco más grande todo el rato 0 28 0 27 0 30
he bloqueado que no haya filtro vale que no haya si en cambio ordeno por drawdown lo contrario 0 7
0 8 0 7 0 6 de acuerdo lo más bajo si ordenamos recovery busca el término medio vale pero el
drawdown tira mucho de por eso al final este shark aunque es un poco como os he dicho antes
falso por por el por demás y ahí cambia es verdad que también da los saltos por retorno pero hay poca
diferencia de esos valores están todo el rato alrededor del 0 todos estos es lo mismo
es prácticamente lo mismo todo esto hay muy muy poca variación de acuerdo de mi poca variación en
el dato de 6 p6 y 10 pero también bastante elevado el tréil bastante elevado el tréil y pero ya
digo con muy poca con muy poca variación pues al final nos hemos quedado con un compromiso pero
vamos a ver vamos a hacer rápidamente porque es un buen ejercicio hemos hemos hecho este del 6 20
y ahora vamos a ver todos estos incluso voy a voy a quitar el este límite vamos a ver por
ejemplo el que mejor retorno da vale que es que no tengo ordenado al revés pero es el canal primero
vale sería 6 0 27 1 vale lo voy a poner que es bastante parecido al que voy a dejar la gestión
monetaria igual para no tocar nada vamos a hacer 6 0 27 1 me lo punto ahí para tener claro luego
cuál es cuál es cuál 6 por de hecho el filtro podría poner si voy a poner así porque así me aclaro
más y sería mejor 6 1 0 27 venga 6 1 0 27 0 27 dejamos toda la gestión monetaria como hemos
hecho el otro para poderlos comparar espero que vuelva a cruz ahí va vale es seguramente se hace
vamos a ver el que menor dada obtiene que es muy es muy raro ya os lo digo pero vamos a verlo
vale sería por canal en ese caso 25 ahora viene el filtro y luego el tréil 0 0 7 vale el que mejor
tiene que es 4 0 24 4 1 0 24 luego los comparamos hoy ahora voy ahora voy ahora voy fran de
contexto a ver este el de net ya lo he hecho no 25 1 0 0 7 25 1 0 0 7 de la segunda fran
que me los acabo de apuntar este recobrimos que damos con uno de la este pero 0 12 aunque
en estar de luego haremos una pasión de dios estaré hecha una es que de hecho lo intentamos
hacer pero maestro entre los problemas que tiene lo que os decía es de optimizando aparte de la
velocidad es que como tarda tanto tiene un problema con gélito que ha tenido mil protestas y mil
demandas que es que exige que esté eslogado mientras hace todo el test y como es extremadamente
lento y lo tú lo dejas un fin de semana los fines de semana muchas veces hacen mantenimiento y al
final muchas veces se tras cuelga entonces es un problema bastante serio porque al final hay
veces que para conseguir acabar una optimización más allá que pueda durar dos días que ya es
un problema lo difícil es que en dos días no se cuelgue y el tiempo real se cuelgue lo que sea y
entonces lo pierde es bastante es increíble como tecnológicamente los problemas que tiene a este
nivel porque hace muchos tiempos mucho tiempo que tiene evoluciones pendientes y el programa
en sí no es que sea malo pero se ha quedado completamente desfasado es actualizado y como
no lo revisan en ese sentido pues claro la tecnología va avanzando los procesadores
van avanzando y él no alta y está ahí un poquito limitado espérate que ya no sé cuál he hecho
cuál no he hecho a ver 25 107 hecho no vale este lo he hecho 6 27 0 1 luego lo revisaré que estén
que estén bien pero ahora voy a hacer el siguiente 4 1 0 24 4 pero 24 aquí lo normal lo que pasa es
lo que os digo esta optimización de 3 de porfolio trader tiene tiene ese problema da pocos datos
entonces los tienes que construir tú el problema es lo que os digo que al ver este problema con
char no hemos podido utilizar el sortino que usamos para las estrategias sueltas entonces hay
que hacerlo para por folio porque pensamos que valía pero hemos visto que no entonces hay que
hacer el sortino para por folio y a veces lo que hemos hecho es hacer varias es decir hacer una
lo bueno es que modificar es muy rápido y como el coste fitness al costo fitness es una fórmula
que tú puedes programar al final le puedes meter varios pasadas recoges varios uno pues le ponen
sortino sharp y el que quieras los pasas todos al excel y entonces ahí es donde ya tienes tú para
hacer distintos cálculos o ratios que puedas calcular directamente en el ex de momento sólo
puedo calcular el recovery utilizar este sharp que insisto que no es el valor correcto pero sí
que es extrapolable a para hacerla para hacer la selección para este era el 4 ya sólo me queda
uno más raro y ahora podremos comparar datos entre ellos vale 1 0 0 se lee bien el maestro
la pantalla ahora ahora ahora no me siguen por cierre pero esto es instrumental y no
no merece mucho la pena pararse mucho en explicaros todo esto es al final simplemente estoy haciendo
todo el porfolio con unos ex concretos trataré de dejarlo mañana a ver si me acaba porque
ese fin de semana he intentado dos veces que maestro me hiciera toda la optimización completa
pero esta optimización que hemos hecho multicharts también se puede hacer pero en multicharts he
tardado unos en hacer la larga de esto tardado unos 15 minutos y maestro se ha colgado después
de llevar cada una de ellas como 20 pico horas y no había acabado esta es la relación y era
lo mismo en verdad era lo mismo mismo código todo igual y esa esa es un poco la comparación
no entonces que ya os lo había comentado alguna vez es un drama de maestro pues es la
sola que es que ya digo es súper potente luego a nivel de informes es brutal ahora
ahora veréis todos los datos que nos saca está fantástico y los hemos revisado bueno
hay uno por ejemplo que no está bien ya lo pasamos pero pero esto sí que sí que están bien y bueno
pues es la lástima comentaba fran comentaba fran que la selección del filtro volatilidad
lo hecho entre 0 y 1 pero que 1 4 tenía mejor que decir estaba una zona robusta de estar sería
mejor pues sí pero ahí a mí me parece podríamos podríamos trabajarlo un poco un poco
más pero me parece sobre optimizarlo me parece demasiado los filtros a mí de norma me cuesta
meter filtros y a este tendencial para la ganancia que he visto ya ya comentado creo que no se lo
metería no se lo metería pero encima si lo metes tiene que ser o no optimizado o muy poco
sabes es decir esa el filtro es la manera de sobre utilizar más porque es cuando tú ya tienes
tu sistema vamos a suponer 6 0 20 es vale venga y ahora le meto un filtro que me va a eliminar
los malos o sea eso he dicho así no te suena a una cosa fácil de sobre optimizar porque al
final le vas a quitar los cientos tres cientos o cientos igual sabes que está muy bien no quitar
la parte mala pero pero el problema es que estás aumentando el riesgo de que de que de que sea una
sobre optimización aunque en el mapa parece robusto aunque en el mapa parece robusto que
entiendo lo que dices y tienes sentido no te digo que no pero le daría más vueltas porque le daría
más vueltas y ya digo granular lo tanto explico es como el filtro no 0 20 ya te digo yo lo sé
optimizado los todos en 0 25 porque porque vierais el mapa bien granulado pero realmente
tampoco me gusta es decir en un sistema en diario con mil y pico trades de verdad prefiero ir de 0 0 5
en 0 0 5 sabes es decir ir a buscar tanto el detalle explico 0 21 0 22 0 23
explicó es decir al final recuerda que lo que estás viendo es lo que ha ido mejor en el pasado
entonces ya te digo al final elegir siempre el mejor el que y esa ya te digo el tema del
incremento es una cosa que es quizá la que más tiene su canal una media esto es muy evidente porque
va de uno en uno vale que sí que no hay mucha historia pero cuando tienes fitos cosas así que
tú puedes hacer 0,1 0,2 pero si por puestos ya podríamos hacer 0 0 1 0 0 2 0 0 3 y por qué
no 0,0 0 0 1 0,0 0 0 2 sabes me entiendes hay que hay que cortarlo sí sí ya sé ya sé que tenía
muchos ya sé que tenía muchos muchos años pero sí sí ya sé que tenía muchos pero el filtro
otro no tenía tantos o sea de cambiar el filtro cada 300 o sea has cambiado 300 o sea eso el
sistema tiene los 400 con el filtro en 0 o el filtro en 1 y de 0 a 1 cambia 300 y de 1 a 4
igual cambiaba 200 ahora lo miramos lo miramos lo miramos porque este sí este es el que tengo
con todos no sí es el que tengo con todos aquí de tener uno a bueno no en ese no lo he hecho es
en el 3 en la opti 3 aquí no aquí te he dado todo el rato sólo sólo el filtro es que fíjate
aquí llevaba la extrema operaciones aquí tenías en 1 o 4 lo que tú dices que te ha gustado es este
como en verde vale este a ti te ha gustado porque bueno te ha dado un recovery bastante más elevado
mejorado ha mejorado sobre todo porque tienes ahí 1 430 este sí que te ha bajado pero de éste a
éste que tienes 103 de diferencia entre ellos o sea poner ese filtro o no ponerlo son 103 de
diferencia y gana un poquito más y baja el verdadero dices o sea está muy bien bueno sí claro si de
aquí cinco años eso se mantiene es verdad ahora eso es seguro que se mantendrá no la realidad es
que eso no es seguro no es seguro que el cero pues decir bueno ya pero el cero le he quitado
un grado de libertad no estamos de acuerdo al final no no he añadido variabilidad a la que yo
meto esto estoy metiendo una tr o sea se metió en una condición más al sistema porque esta
no trabaja soy ignorando el atr yo aquí le estoy ya asumiendo que cuando el atr de un día con el
atr de un mes por multiplicado por una 4 sea mayor no pere y de esa manera le he quitado
siempre que es un 3 por acción de media 3 por acción entonces no no no es una certeza fran es
que esto va así o sea no no no es una certeza o sea no es no es que yo te diga esto seguro que
luego no irá no no para nada no te lo puedo decir no sería serio decirte eso no lo sé seguro pero
estoy añadiendo un grado de certidumbre más para el beneficio que me da no me renta me explico es
decir para el beneficio que me dan no me renta a mí no me parece suficiente para yo para añadir
grados de libertad para añadir posibilidades al sistema de oscilar de que siempre que añades
como mínimo ya ves una y a veces son varias porque es la condición o sea es el valor de
la tierra y que la tierra de hoy sea menor que la tierra mensual esos más o menos son dos para
añadir de dos necesito necesito que me convenza mucho pero de todas maneras lo estudiaría más
decir miraría esto miraría esto en el gráfico muchas acciones y la otra cosa que ahora no hemos
hecho esas que ahora lo vamos a hacer el maestro un poco y un poco pero también lo miraría gráfico
nosotros miramos mucho pero miramos mucho ahora esto lo miraría el gráfico en distintas acciones
miraría el gráfico ya lo haremos ya lo haremos aunque no lo hagamos hoy lo haré porque a esto
tengo que volver para necesito ver un sortino ahí para ser más cómodo tienes entonces necesito verlo
lo veré pero el filtro no es no es no es ni concluyente ni granulandolo en 1.4 si el filtro
es jose donett sigo sigo las preguntas porque ya estamos en hora de preguntas y hay que ir
contestando comenta en esta línea jose que si el filtro quitar a 503 sería más válida entiendo
si sería más válido si si sería más válido sería más válido en este en el caso de los filtros
es un poco es un poco al revés y por eso es como lo diría no es que sea contra el tuitivo es contra
el tuitivo para lo que he explicado me está diciendo siempre contra más tres mejor vale
pero ahora me dices que si el filtro quita más es mejor y que quedamos bueno las dos cosas son
verdad las dos cosas son verdad quiere decir que para que el filtro me quite tengo que tener
muchos antes si no ya no me vales es decir si tengo mil ya no filtró me entiendes ya no filtró
ya no ya no estoy suficientemente cómodo para que eso baje más me explicó entonces pero
evidentemente el filtro valida el filtro valida quitando el filtro valida actuando las reglas
para evaluarlas tiene que tienen que implicar cambios si no si no implica cambios no está
validada y la significación pasa por ahí vale porque cada regla tenga un número de tres donde
actúen y en distintos momentos distintas condiciones de mercado etcétera significación y
representatividad significación y representatividad significación la verdad las estadísticas
representatividad la de actuar en distintos mercados vale por eso que ahora lo hemos metido 20 a esto
para ver esta curva en 20 bien aquí tenemos un resumen vale de entrada aquí ratios que no valen
para nada el esto que veis aquí si lo veis es el total retorno partido por máxima darolón aquí no
vale para nada aquí no vale para nada porque bueno vale bueno habiendo hecho que su manera
vale un poco pero para regular regular porque al final es lo que os decía antes es decir el
drawdown no lo puedo meter en porcentaje que es verdad que aquí como yo he regulado en 100
acciones y vengo con gestión monetaria que es muy importante muy importante porque porque es muy
importante porque si venís aquí a ver la lista de trades pues yo al final he ido exponiendo si tú
multiplicas por ejemplo de igual esta acción hemos comprado 60 por 33.14 al final he comprado
1988 dólares que es más o menos el 2% que habíamos hablado al inicio 2000 dólares vale entonces
si yo siempre he ido exponiendo esa misma cantidad pues es mejor sería mejor el porcentaje sí pero
como yo siempre voy exponiendo bueno un 2% de la cuenta ya estoy haciendo porcentaje porque ahora
tengo 100.000 2% pero cuando tenga 200.000 pues será el doble pues ya voy exponiendo siempre una
cantidad que depende del porcentaje gracias a ese 2% 2% entonces las cantidades están más o menos
ecualizadas pero como lo mismo que se ha hecho en el excel os he dicho no está mal recovery sirve
pero sería mejor aún en porcentaje sería mejor vale pero aquí como ya tenemos esa tenemos el
recalculado tenemos algunos datos más que nos sirve tenemos el tráiler real aquí muy elevado
porque porque hemos metido la exposición a casi el 200 hemos metido un poco un poco elevado a la
exposición pero aquí sí que tenemos el triple r a 0 34 aquí tenemos a 0 92 carros como cambia
0 0 0 6 y 1 0 6 aquí el que los cambios son bestiales el uno es saber cuál era este 6 1 0 27
ese era el primero bueno el que era por net profit era por net profit al final equilibra
bastante curiosa ver a los cero de la onda de 60 la otra tenía un 70 70 y pico como está muy
expuesto sí sí sí está muy expuesto está muy expuesto fíjate estamos componiendo 25 29 por ciento
y aquí que he hecho 0 88 que hay un fallo y aquí me he equivocado que he pasado con este 25 1 0 27
0 0 7 y porque ahora tampoco tengo que haber hecho algo mal no ves que no vale nada te va
a haber configurado algo mal los clothes falls trailing 0 0 7 no bueno esperate esperate esperate
esperate que este era el día de la hora no está bien es que se no no hace nada vez era
un poco solo se tiene muy poco straights diría muy poco straights no era de aquí era de aquí
sí sí claro grabo muy poco no se ha ganado muy poco el de era el de máximo el de máximo
era el de máximo era el de máximo era bueno aquí por mirarlo rápido en el sumario fijaros
simplemente profit factor aquí tenemos 39 aquí tenemos 59 73 147 porque tanto por profit factor
como por r incluso que por sharp aunque más parecido es el 6 0 el 6 1 0 27 actuando el filtro
que se quedaba más más profit que hemos estado impuestos aquí todos 6 6 1 0 27 correcto y este
era el de antes 6 0 6 0 0 20 ser 1 43 tan notablemente notablemente alejado notablemente
alejado bueno vamos a ver vamos a ver el siguiente día si podemos sacar el sortino vía por folio
porque no está no está sacado no está no está sacado y sacar el sharp bien vía via cartera aquí
ya os sale ya ya tenemos positivo y es otra cosa porque se está calculado bien se ha calculado bien
y tiene mejor mejor ya veis que sé que hay algún dato negativo pero este quedaba cancelar aquí lo
que pasa que realmente la exposición es un poco elevada teníamos que haberla regulado más hemos
llegado a exponernos al al al 200 pero dos veces nos ha apalancado hasta dos veces
claro tenemos niveles de trowdown muy jeves a nivel de por folio tenemos trowdowns de aquí del 60
aquí del 60 aquí del 30 para ver si aquí tiene menos trowdown aquí del 60 y será el 79 bastante
bastante elevado bueno este tipo de que recordar que no está no estamos evaluando el por folio
para operarlo así es lo que os comentaba estamos evaluando la idea por evaluando la idea y luego
ya decidiríamos cómo lo operábamos aquí tenemos muchas acciones en negativo lógicamente luego
una vez el sistema está validado yo luego lo operaré a lo mejor no necesariamente las 10 mejores
pero así que serán de las mejores de acuerdo es decir al final yo valido la idea en las 100
acciones porque eso me da mayor robustez digamos que la idea la pongo más a prueba en acciones
incluso no han ganado vale y esto lo que os decía o sea esto también incluso aquí incluso en
el por folio trader que no es tan no me dará tanta información pero este mismo mirar para que veáis
la comparación que es interesante de ver pero pongo aquí este que nos ha dado aquí mejor podríamos
decir que era 6 1 0 27 lo podemos ver aquí 6 1 0 27 para nosotros a 0 esto va a 0 esto va a 0 27
y ahora se le hacemos backtest y aquí ya veréis que cambia mucho la cosa aquí también tenemos
un montón de datos esto cambia mucho hasta hasta más que allí es que lo hemos puesto bien 6 0
filtro 1 por nosotros con el 1 a 0 27 0 0 0 a bueno a 100 por ciento está expuesto que no puede ir
así no puede ir así está muy expuesto a tener un drawdown 46 y tengo el money management a mente
por folio 2 por ciento está bien está bien está el 2 por ciento es aquí ya hemos controlado mejor
porque le hemos expuesto hemos controlado la exposición claro también tiene un factor de
146 y ganar 52 mil poco claro todo lo uno depende del otro no uno depende del otro pero aquí por
ejemplo mirar lo que os quería enseñar antes la correlación de los retornos mensuales de acuerdo
de todas las 100 acciones fijaros que hay datos en negativo porque hay acciones que pierden que
pero que siendo todo en el nasdaq 100 claro es que apel con microsoft tiene 0 66 apel con google
0 48 con amazon 0 55 con envidia 0 32 con facebook 0 29 que son acciones directoras de acuerdo están
ordenadas están ordenadas por capitalización vale que es decir que todas las que veis primeras son
acciones super top para elegir y fijaros su nivel de correlación bajar aquí no sé si se llega a
ver bien esperados que os voy a poner el foco lo que sea mejor con el foco es ahí fijaros ahí veis
microsoft mirar la columna para abajo es 0 66 0 67 0 53 0 69 0 56 0 55 0 40 con tesla pero 48
0 36 0 39 0 68 51 es decir es el mismo sistema en el mismo frame vale sus correlaciones mensuales
son relativamente moderadas pero no son 0 809 está bien tiene una diversificación moderada que es
muy mejora lógicamente muy mejor vale entonces aquí fijaros que ya con una exposición más
controlada tenemos datos de retorno poquito más estables es una curva bastante justa bastante
muy muy justo bastante virgen pero es un sistema muy justo pero con este nivel de profit factor
ese nivel de retorno acepta algo de apalancamiento y tiene algo de mejora por por delante lógicamente
tiene mucha mejora por aquí además hemos cargado pocos años espérate que vamos a ver cómo tarda
poco está con la serie vamos a meter desde el 2007 al bienes pasado 2% mira vamos a meter un 3
nos vas a poner un poquito más y veis ya tenemos un sharp calculado bien a 29 45 es decir el sharp
al uno es un sharp bajito es un sistema justo pero bueno poco a poco lo podemos hacer crecer
a uno el sistema de hecho este set simplemente es el de mayor retorno no es el que mejor equilibra
aquí ahora podíamos mirar mirar varios pero y hemos mejorado un poquito ha sufrido bastante
aquí porque es verdad que con este nivel de de ratio del trailing pues le cuesta le cuesta salirse
esto ya os digo habían sets este set tiraba más para el retorno pero teníamos alguno que tiraba
un poco más al equilibrio no aquí podíamos encontrar alguno que mejorara esto a cambio de
mejor un retorno un poco peor es un poco la que hay que fijaros hemos ganado un poco de histórico
como tenemos ratios negativos en varios varias acciones a los ves en facebook perdemos dinero
en google en una de las google también porque al final tienen muy pocas acciones con este nivel
de exposición con este canal y con este ratio realmente opera muy poco cada una de las acciones
de acuerdo pero muy poco por eso al final nos vemos obligados a meter pues un análisis global que al
final nos pueda meter más acciones para que al final nos pueda meter 1.100 trades desde el 2007
desde 2007 nos mete 1.100 trades todavía no dejamos un set elegido porque me gustaría me gustaría
poder ver una optimización en el sarte para el sortino de porfolio que aquí sí que lo veo pero
no lo veo optimizando porque es una cosa bastante extraña por parte de multicharts ahí en los
foros de multicharts están con varios mensajes al respecto es decir que tienes sharp metido
como función tienes sortino metido como fines y que a mí no lo tienes como fines ya por defecto
de optimización es un poco extraño es porque si ya lo tienes metido dentro del programa o sea lo
das ese ratio lo das lo puedes perfectamente usar como ratio de iana porque es un dato que
estás calculando si tú me lo estás calculando y aquí pero curiosamente lo da para el performance
pero no lo da como ratio de iana lo tienes que meter tú por código y el que tienes metido por
sistema nos sirve por lo que os decía tienes que hacer específico de porfolio de acuerdo entonces
tienes ese problema pues es un tanto curioso pero pero así es vale bien para el próximo día vamos
a tomar una decisión una decisión respecto a este sistema tal como está es decir en una configuración
de full tendencia vale de full tendencia a aquel que quiera y que lo tenga los recursos que tengan
software los conocimientos para hacerlo pues si lo quiere también hacer alguna propuesta que es
súper bienvenida como deberes para casa que quiero ir mandando algunos vale la regla de entrada
simplemente es esta no tiene más es decir es cierre por encima del canal que es por cierres
vale por el número de velas y en la apertura de la siguiente vela compra vale sí que para evitar
que comprar acciones negativas hemos hecho porque muchos años puede pasar cierre mayor que cero
eso es con el t1 es el filtro pero si vale cero es true si el filtro vale cero no actúa que no
esté comprado y que haya par filtro estará una regulación que pasa pero que no actúa que al
menos tenga una vela cerrada para que no compren la cierre y la misma vela vuelva a entrar que al
menos haya pasado una vela desde que ha cerrado y esto que el total trecha igual hacer esto para
que abra al principio vale porque si no no compraría al requerir al requerir que sea distinto de largo
no compraría entonces es una conexión que se suele poner para que empiece a operar y ya pero ya
estamos a la regla de entrada es esta no tiene no tiene más luego lo otro es la gestión monetaria y
la regla de salida por trailing esto me comprometo en lo que queda de semana es decir hoy pues antes
del viernes de acuerdo en ya subiros el código el código así como está vale eso subiré en texto
y os subiré un pdf con una con un con el seudo código con el seudo código con el seudo código
y escrito escrito para que ya la podáis tener y jugar en todas estas condiciones el trailing
que actúa es este de aquí si el present el que es mayor que cero vale lo inicializa la variable
y hasta si está largo es el valor máximo entre el máximo menos el máximo por el trailing o el
teléfon que ya tiene calculado porque sólo puede subir un trailing acordar esta es la condición que
lo controla decir máximo menos el máximo por el porcentaje y ese es el precio y hasta ese es el
precio que simplemente con esta condición te aseguras que no puede bajar no es por atr se
podía hacer por atr pero los querido hacer este caso sólo para hacerlo así por antagé super simple
más simple no puede ser super super simple vale y visto aquí por ejemplo en el gráfico de alguno
de ellos para acabar viendo alguno el informe el informe si es el informe bueno lo vemos aquí
en un momento en cualquiera me creo son mismo venga que valoros tenemos postos aquí bueno ese
es el 6 0 20 es el 6 0 20 que estábamos viendo viendo antes creo que ahora estamos viendo 6 con
el filtro en 1 y 0 27 todavía menos pero no menos ya veis claro es un sistema que deja correr deja
correr se ha comprado deja correr el sistema de muy largo plazo por eso la única manera de
evaluarlo es metiéndolo en varias acciones de acuerdo y que cuando el mercado va a entrar
lateral pues sufre sufre mucho porque hay que fijaros acaba entrando otra vez el canal no está
bien ajustado y vuelve a entrar el canal no está no está bien no está bien porque no están 6 están
20 6 es muy rápido entrar muy rápido esta es la diferencia habéis visto que había varios
varias zonas esta esta es la versión súper rápida de entrar habían otras versiones hay
que acabar de hay que acabar de elegir aquel que quiera proponer con el código del sistema
que le daremos y demás alguna que nos lo envíe nos lo puede enviar lo voy a poner el disco lo
puede enviar al email y yo me comprometo a responderle otra cosa que queda pendiente
para el día siguiente vamos a hacer esto acabar de tomar una decisión acabar de tomar una decisión
con nuestro sortino de porfolio decisión de parámetros de esta versión como está que hacemos
con los cortos esto es lo que os quería poner para casa unido con esto aquel que quiera en
este set up en este código que haría con el lado corto si alguien quiere proponer o quiere
trabajarlo o simplemente puede proponerlo bien trabajándolo o bien
o bien filosóficamente podemos hacer las dos cosas me valen las dos cosas aquel que
quiera trabajarlo porque puede hacerlo ya que lo haga el que no quiera trabajarlo porque no es
capaz simplemente que le que lo que lo conceptualice y que diga pues mira yo creo que en los cortos
en esta versión haría esto esto esto y porque en acciones en este mismo set up en acciones que
hacemos con los cortos y luego ya lo que vendría es lo mejor tiene que ver con esto vale es que
que otras variaciones hacemos este comentamos que el don chan es un mecanismo de entrar en
tendencia pero es un mecanismo muy útil para hacer break out entonces esto ahora con lo que
tiene ya en el código se puede hacer break out se puede hacer un break out como como
haríamos sobre que tratamos de desarrollar este serían un poco las cosas pendientes respecto a
esta estrategia que deberíamos de liquidarlo ya para entrar en otra en otra cosa no le metamos
más conceptos ya sé que le podríamos meter una tr le podemos meter mil cosas ya lo haremos de
acuerdo el sistema este lo vamos a dejar así con un don chan sencillito entre en la versión
tendencial que es muy mejorable lo vamos a dejar así y cortos y haremos un break out con esta con
este código también vale y a partir de ahí seguiremos en otras en otras cosas vale a ver
si me queda alguna pregunta como si puedes subir el código un poco antes sería lo suyo para trabajar
con él sí sí sí a ver si mañana me he puesto te he dicho antes el viernes para para dar límite
pero pero antonio el segundo código yo te lo voy a pasar pero ya lo tienes ya lo tienes quiero
decir que el segundo código es explicado lo he explicado todas las clases que yo te lo voy a
pasar e insisto que te lo voy a pasar pero si ahora luego que yo te vuelvo a subir la clase
me oyes lo escribes aparte que lo he enseñado lo he enseñado es decir es que la la es que el
setup de entrada es este de verdad o sea todo lo demás todo todo lo demás es accesorio esto es
esto es el setup de entrada es el setup de entrada si cierra por encima del canal de n cierres hemos
visto 6 hemos visto 20 etcétera compra en la apertura de la siguiente vela esto es lo que
lo pasaré y el trailing es lo único que tiene un poco más de desarrollo a nivel de programación
pero el concepto es súper básico o sea es el mayor el máximo que haya hecho el precio desde que
abres el más en ese caso sí que es el máximo de ese máximo siempre le va restando un porcentaje
ese es el stop trailing cada vela cambia con cada vela que cambia si hace un máximo porque si no
hace un máximo no actualiza de acuerdo es decir sólo el máximo del máximo le restas un porcentaje
y eso era lo que era un 027 un 020 de acuerdo es hora que es un 20% entonces es un poco la idea
pero insisto que me comprometo a si mañana no llego voy a hacer lo máximo para que el miércoles
lo podáis tener lo podáis lo podáis tener el miércoles vale y qué más qué más qué más o sea
se puede preguntar si se puede aplicar trailing esto y esto para la vez aseguró una pérdida esto
fija sí sí sí es es posible y tiene sentido pero en este caso y el sentido a ver depende
del tipo que vos es realmente digo eh depende del tipo que vos o sea en el trailing que hemos
puesto nosotros en el trailing que hemos puesto nosotros mucho mucho sentido no tiene vale porque
ya hemos puesto porque hay muchos el concepto clásico de trailing hay muchas veces que se activa
a partir de cierta cantidad pues en esos casos mucha gente sí que usa un esto un esto de seguridad
podemos decir acordaros cuando hablamos un poco del esto de seguridad no y que entra ya nada más
abrir pues un poco por si se lía no es que me saque no pues no tener que no me saca pero en
nuestro caso el telín se activa desde la entrada en el momento del cálculo se calcula del cierre
anterior y en el momento que el precio que acaba la barra en que ha entrado ya entra en juego el
valor máximo que haya o el cierre anterior o el máximo que haya hecho ese día el máximo que haya
hecho ese día actúa de trailing y entonces ya tienes trailing claro que es un 20 por ciento por
eso has visto algunos aquí como este o bueno incluso otros peores que se va se va para abajo y a tomar
viento a tomar viento el problema de los tendenciales puros es este que si tú quieres un tendencial
puro y quieres tres como esta locura de que te pilla toda la subida no esto pues claro solo
ahí dejándolo dejándole tragándote estas cosas también ese problema porque si yo le pongo una
salida por tiempo que va muy bien y evitará mucho esto que evitará también que pille la
por eso decía que un tendencial es bastante desagradecido es muy desagració te decía el puro
luego están los breakout que también son tipo de tendencial que ya se manejan mejor y que este
lo haremos también mercado vale entonces conceptualmente si se puede pero en esta
configuración tal como está no tiene demasiado sentido porque ya actúa siempre este lo que pasa
que le da mucho margen le da mucho margen pero este desde el primer momento que entra ya va
calculando aquí le calcula un 27 pero no ha saltado ahora para que veas este aquí le
pongo 10 por ciento y seguramente salta salta ahí salta aquí salta aquí es un poco la idea no es
claro yo lo tengo siempre siempre calcula este este que hemos hecho nosotros imagínate que le
pongo 005 no va a parar de salirse todo el rato es ya cambiado completamente el sistema es otro
sistema no para entrar a salir a salir a salir a salir a salir que cuesta mucho porque el precio
va haciendo sus oscilaciones y alguna vez oye y ahora un trocho grande pero la mayoría de veces
no porque se va a salir todo el rato y ahí está el equilibrio de los tendenciales este es el
problema en los sensores que para pillar largos recorridos y no caer en esto hay que dejarlo
sufrir claro que hay maneras de utilizarlo más para evitar las otras pero un tendencial puro es
uno de los casos de trelling aunque ya os lo comenté en la teoría es verdad que trelling
acopla bastante acopla bastante pero el porcentaje acopla menos entonces acopla bastante quiere decir
que lo lo vas a lo metes ahí pero 25 y luego empezarás a ver que a veces ha degradado ha
degradado a ver un segundo que te leo es que a veces que va directo a pérdidas se hacen más
es que el trelling hay veces que se va directo a pérdidas igual por el cierre o algo y hace más
de lo configurado a que te pierde más de lo que tienes esperado que es decir depende cómo lo
tengas votado si lo pones desde el principio si lo pones en principio que se siempre puesto en
mercado al final claro te puede pillar un gapos aquí en este caso vas a tendencia y te vas a
tragar claro los resultados el otro día lo hablaba en el directo del jueves había no sé qué acción
había caído 15 pues te lo tragas claro esto hay en acciones tienes ese problema aquí muy
diversificado y porque te lo tragas en tendencia tenés el problema pero ya veremos otro tipo de
estrategias cuidado es decir al final ahora estamos viendo esta pero pero que tiene su lado
bueno y su lado malo al final y por eso la idea es tener varias tener una así tener otra que te
lo compensa y ésta te queda enganchada pero a lo mejor tienes otra que había iba corto en petróleo
y no sé qué hay que ir diversificando los tendenciales ya digo que son de hecho cuando
uno no tiene mucha experiencia son sistemas bastante poco llevaderos vale lo hablamos
en la teoría normalmente es más tendencial hay más llevadero un sistema antitenencial porque
porque el antitencial no deja no tiene colas largas en cambio los tendenciales o sea con
dentro lateral no para de fallar no para de fallar no para de fallar y te devuelve mucho el mercado
por no sé jose bien bien no sé exactamente esto que dices un 2 y que te hago un 4 no sé no sé
por qué que no tengas un problema de cálculo sino lo que te digo los gaps claro los gaps y
sí pero vaya el gap está afectado igual de un stop que de está afectado igual o sea no tiene
más si está bien calculado no tiene no tiene más tendrás alguno 100% tendrás alguno 100% que
te va a hacer más o sea es que eso es así no tiene mayor mayoría tendrás muchos hechos que
te hará que te hará más pero pero vaya tanto en uno como en otro tanto en esto como si no bueno
explica pasar a nosotros un email y tal y explicando lo mejor y lo miramos lo miramos a ver por qué
porque te pasa eso tendencia al puro no es usual por nuestro blog fijado mejor trailing la verdad
que era es que se pende en que que vayas depende en que vayas un esto en un tendencial en un
tendencial puro el trailing y generando somos súper amigos de los que los digo estamos ahora
empezando las prácticas como el que dice vale es la primera estrategia que hemos hecho vale pero
si algún tipo de sistema va bien el trailing es en el tendencial en el tendencial puro si alguno
vale va bien este tu aquí puede nosotros operando en live pero no usamos vamos a esto pero no es
tendencial puro no es tendencial puro en un tendencial puro ya digo el trailing es el caso
que más que más sentido tiene sobre todo en acciones sobre todo en acciones buscando el largo
recorrido que es un poco la idea este sistema que lo puedes configurar así pero no es la idea ya
ese sistema y por eso lo hemos metido en las acciones es que corra vale es un sistema para
correr esta es su idea su sentido y claro es un o sea es un sistema que cuando netflix sube un
200 por ciento lo pilla me entiendes ahora eso tiene un precio me entiendes eso tiene un precio
cuando meta está en lateral un montón de tiempo pues te lo tragas ahora en cambio está en el
que alucinas pero claro tu imagínate ya en sus está básico que no no no no voy ahora a 6020
vale que solo hablamos y le quito el filtro vale esto ya es configuración básica original sin
hacer nada el largo que lleva en meta está comprado ahora mismo en 119 20 están 470
400 por ciento claro eso sólo lo pillas así sólo pillas así claro a costa de eso aquí se te ha
tragado tres hostias que te han dejado la cuenta bonita pero hay que estar dimensionado para ello
y cuando está estado en lateral pues está cosido también claro bueno en estas etapas ha aguantado
muy bien porque claro tiene mucho margen pero hay acciones o yo que sé cuando netflix mira
netflix es tremendo porque netflix tuvo ahora sí pero a tener una época hace tiempo y ahí a la
tragadita perdona venga comprado en 95 98 y te sacan 300 bueno tiene lo bueno y tiene lo
malo pero cuando se pasa una época mala pues te hace polvo pero es aquí el tiempo que está que
no hace nada si no si no si no al final coge tendencia en el tendencial ya digo es el caso
que te va a pensar con esto puro tiene que tener otra salida que me lo decía la verdad de antonio
si yo aquí este sistema tiene puesto un esto pero como salgo tengo que necesito otras sí o sí porque
si no vuelve yo te desactivo el trailing ahora y te pongo el mismo en stop el mismo 0 20 no sale
nunca entiendes porque no cae 0 20 el precio de entrada nunca ya tiene que caer 0 20 de aquí
explicó es decir al final no es igual 0 10 necesita otra salida cambio el trailing no
el trailing garantiza que no necesita nada más entonces si yo no quiero muchos grados de libertad
y demás quiero simple trailing me soluciona que sólo puedo usar esa salida yo aquí sólo tengo un
y una salida nada más las las pérdidas se pregunta antonio si se podían compensar con el lado
corto bastante bien bueno si se puede claro esa es la idea pero es muy difícil hacer cortos en
acciones antonio es muy difícil es posible pero es muy difícil con un tendencial es muy complicado
es muy complicado porque vuelve mucho es decir mira esto es un ejemplo muy bueno de hecho mira
es que lo podemos hacer rápidamente ya para ir acabando podemos hacer mira el mismo lo vamos
a poner corto ahora mismo vale el don chan porque esto no nos vale te pongo el don chan
lo que lo cambiaron pero te lo pongo igual 20 0 20 vale 20 0 20 20 0 20 hay perdón pero cortos
true 0 20 no activa el corto no lo activa estoy atontado y si se activa lo que pasa
igual no ha saltado pero si parece lo que salte alguna vez 20 20 20 no claro ya sé que pasa ya
sé que pasa ya sé que pasa que con él sin el filtro lo tengo mal configurado es fallo míos
porque como la volatilidad es inverso lo activo la volatilidad y así
es un problema de que no es que sea un problema en sí pero que no bueno si es un problema porque
no le he previsto activar el corto sin activar el filtro así pierde casi seguro en el lado corto
digo es que pierdes que se arruina entonces claro pues lo bajamos pero entonces no era bien el
largo tienes que hacer que hay que buscarle un set up para el corto es decir el mismo set up en
acciones el largo y corto es muy complicado hay poca algún tipo de sistema pero no no un
tendencial en un tendencial no lo vas a conseguir en este tipo no lo vas a conseguir entonces aquí
y hay que ir a otra cosa aquí la otra casa aquí en un corto pues no es lo que os decía ya no os
digo porque si no ya pero no corto hay que ir a otra cosa este mismo sistema hemos puesto salida
por tiempo esto tp aquí la otra cosa en un corto en acciones se puede para que la otra cosa hay que
salir rápido de acuerdo hay que salir entonces en este set up es muy complicado porque las
tendencias son muy abruptas es decir te entran entran muy bien así este caen y mira te has
rebotado y te has sacado antes encima ya te mete aquí y aquí aún mira no salvas pero es
súper complicado es súper complicado es súper complicado vuelve muchísimo el precio vuelve
y le cuesta muchísimo rebota muy violentamente luego vuelve a caer y la vez aquí cae ya está fuera
final largo otra vez corto estás corto ahí estás es muy es muy duro que el mercado vuelve mucho
muy escarpado es mucho más escarpado cayendo que subiendo el mercado se resiste mucho caer
para que me entiendas existe mucho que hay algún momento que no pero en norma acabas
perdiendo mucha pasta en cortos pero nosotros el nasa que lo operamos el lado corto pero
este año hemos perdido el largo plazo pero el año pasado hemos perdido con apolo vale ya la última
pregunta antonio comenta no que si a mejor bajar el frame más tendencia vaquista más
bueno puedes bajar el frame o puedes operar otro tipo de sistema antonio otro tipo de
sistema si no no hace falta buscar tendencia es decir puedes buscar tendencia en el lado largo
y ir anti tendencia en corto y también puedes buscar una nota y freme no digo que no pero es
que el mercado es fractal es decir el lado corto tendrás ganarás unas cosas pero perderás otras
es decir no no necesariamente es más sencillo es más difícil es más difícil pero sí sí que
hay algunas cosas que te pueden ir bien ese nivel sobre todo te puede ir bien en el control del
riesgo el perder menos cuando falle no te puede ir mejor ahí pero también te va a sacar sabes
o sea también así que no más tendencia el puro es complicado es complicado ahí hay que
buscar más bien break out anti tendencial por la tiri y breakout rotura para salir buscar salir
por tiempo o por tp tener un objetivo el total o al menos la mitad hay que jugar un poco con eso
vale bien ya os he dicho un poco la agenda del día que viene y para los que queráis trabajar
pues lo podéis poner bien en el discord y nos lo envíais por email vale lo que digo máximo
bienes pero intentaré por todos los medios que el miércoles ya esté subido el pseudocódigo y la
explicación que la idea que tenemos es hacerlo en un pdf donde nos aportamos la ficha un poco
una explicación de cada sistema vale y tener así poderla la podéis tener como como documentación
del curso de acuerdo pues nada más amigos os veo el viernes os veo os veo el viernes gracias en
las otras palabras hay el viernes que digo el viernes pues bien lunes bueno jueves el que quiera
ya sabe que estoy en directo para todos los para quien quiera los clientes para para todo el que
quiera interactuar con con nosotros públicamente pues ahí estamos y si no la clase el lunes que
viene de acuerdo en un par de horitas está el vídeo subido hasta pronto familia os veo chao